or hopefully uh our good friends at
Google will allow us to a half's episode
but it's going to wait for stream health
and your beef right now I want to
retweet it - yeah will retweet soon as I
see that but testing testing testing
testing are we signing out here your
song yeah we some fool I attic or a chat
how we sound a chat we some said all
right I'm gonna hit the tweet again
though just to let the lords know that
we back I'm off this year's pop I'm a
hatter my joint off - sorry about that
guys some technical difficulty with
stadia the fools was hatin they want us
to talk I'll talk today
no one's gonna be you know what it is
was place things you can't hold us down
okay they really Shawn Leighton didn't
leave he just went on attack we are live
again 2.0 welcome to the realm you know
what the deal is and if you got your
intro in wolf but brother the difficult
game Conqueror
Lord of reviews and the house doing
pretty good you know this is this is a
really I Oh
you know I'm in a week ahead we we the
week after this definitely doing pretty
good like I said earlier oh we already
got a WoW a q-tip diamond brother so we
appreciate that yeah Yahoo rockin doing
the the Pokemon competitive getting that
Pokemon team together cuz that that
press start discourse sound a little too
cocky yes
[Laughter]
yeah yeah all right and of course I'm
most technical Gaming Lord the solo game
who lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra Davis mr.
off my profile Illuminati and Lord
patron of the iron bank mommy
Lord sovereign I doing sir chillin good
morning gentlemen
I got to play a little more play till
yesterday still a fantastic game getting
through that great plan I don't know why
I've been playing the show I'm playing
the show right now you'll be playing
ever for you t-shirts inside the
teespring store right now join crew
check it out I want you to put that who
did there for you emoji up right now
let's fill Dominus Maximus are we doing
a crown your load right now we can do
that before the first talk because I
want to know how bad our laws right
because I know I lost I just don't know
how bad and of course I was gonna think
about doing to do it so for you like
[Laughter]
this
aka the excess gamer oh the Lord God
king of the statues who demands nothing
less do their premium experience and is
the leader
the fraud alert move it oh sorry I'm
doing you know how I'm doing it is
you'll shout out the but Crawford last
night for a fight that nobody cared
about and Bob Arum keeps stuffing them
in envelopes and milling them out to
crack
I mean I'm so tired of but not getting
exactly what but you know deserves bud
deserves to have these great fights with
the Sean Paul is the Danny a Garcia's
you know of the PBC he really needs to
jump ship and Bob Arum has told us that
he has him lock stock and barrel he even
said that but Crawford after he finished
fighting will still be owned by me now I
understand that that sounds a little bit
on occasion sir I'm sorry I need to help
you but you have Xbox but but is he's an
extreme talent you know but had a little
moments in that fight because he's not
fighting he's not cherry-picking but
he's not fighting the fights that you
want to fight you know you you want to
get these good fights and I felt real
sorry for bud last night because bud
needs to be a pay-per-view star you know
and to get up for these wack fights and
I'm not saying the guy is wack I'm just
saying that the hype isn't there right
you know and he needs definitely to have
these signature fights in his prime and
he's in his crime when it was time to
take old boy out he took him out and he
definitely did what he was supposed to
do and he's getting paid his amount of
money but he needs to be at superstar
status level you know he comes in shape
all the time um Andy what is the ruin
yeah you know this guy comes in shape
all the time he gives a hundred and ten
percent and he's the epitome of a true
champion he can box southpaw Orthodox
you know that means left hand or right
hand
the guy's a boxer puncher he is a pure
talent and we're not gonna get a chance
to see him shine the way he is because
we're looking for arrow spins to you
know bring this guy up by the bootstraps
and that's the only fight that Bob Arum
will allow bud to have because bud will
probably lose to Porter and he will have
a terrible time fighting Danny Garcia um
so I really don't understand what's
gonna happen next for this guy but I'm
rooting for him 110 percent
I know starvin got a chance to watch the
fight I want to know his view on a fight
and I know he wants to UFC that I didn't
get a chance to watch last night I mean
I'm in on bud honestly I feel the same
way I think but he needs to be put in a
fight where he just he's gonna be able
to shine because he is that type of
talent that said oh shout out to I
forgot his opponent's name but I mean he
was that he he what he did was take it
too but in a way that bud was not
expecting he expected but he expected to
sort of but expected him to sort of
attack him from the jump but he didn't
he was calm he was composed he was
boxing with them and I sort of threw
butt off and I think that's where when
you talk about Floyd
that's where Floyd's greatness lies
Floyd's ability to think on his feet and
change up strategy in the middle of a
fight is unparalleled that is why he is
the greatest cuz bud got tucked
yesterday in a way that I never thought
I'd see so that was interesting to me
but I do feel what King says like he
needs to be putting these fights way you
need to be making more money and he's be
put in these fights where he's gonna be
on a big platform shout out to the 110
yeah I was watching right now oh great
look you taking my shine for me oh thank
you for rocking with us buddy
real quick UFC 245 three main events
three minutes let's go first with the
lioness let me go get some subway don't
get the jarred sandwich no doubt the
clutch man zero one $2 super chat the
series x microsoft answer to insomniac
tweet all right soft get that fight
night what's going on triple main event
let's go first with the lioness Amanda
defending her title once again we'll get
all the super shots after the combat all
mm-hmm after Germaine de random mierda
randomly uh honestly I was not a big fan
of the random II because she ran away
from cyborg and she did not want to
fight cyborg but she she came back and
she changed up her game a little bit and
I was glad to see that she got in there
with Nunez and to be honest on the feet
on the feet you could tell that Nunez
was a little bit outgunned around and
your enemy boxing position a length a
length was was was allowing her to touch
Nunez in a way she had not been touched
in quite some time and Nunez did what I
think max Holloway those grappling and I
stood here you pause that the proper
thing and took her down day and night as
much as she could
Duran Duran to me just does not have
takedown defense not at all just all she
has is defense on it she doesn't have
anything offensive on the ground that
was absolutely crazy and she no game and
you know what Nunez exposed what she
needed to expose cuz otherwise it would
have been a problem oh it was a problem
last night from the finish so she did
the smart thing and she retained the
title now awesome max Holloway federal
championship against Alexander volcán
offski volcán Oskie is an absolute beast
he sound like a piece of oak enough oh
and this is a small dude he's not a big
dude and he went in there and acted
honestly he kind of beat max pillar to
post and Max was in there the boxing was
good but volcán oski hit him with power
the legs the leg kicks on both legs but
both of max Max's legs were destroyed
max was in there the thing is I think
max falls in love with his boxing to a
fault he could have tried to take Vulcan
Oski down and I think walking out she's
a great ground fired as well so it would
have been interesting but max was
definitely getting beaten on on the
stand-up and he should have tried to
change it up and he didn't and he lost
his title and I owe nothing
you know Max's corner I don't like when
you don't you're not honest with your
fighter or a friend you got him champ
you got people what you're doing well
you're losing sovereign maybe they knew
that if they told him to switch it up he
was gonna get knocked out it is just one
of him you know to get the participation
trophy I guess man but I you know in the
last round when it's 30 minutes left in
the round
and 30 seconds left and around and
they're like oh he's hitting him with
the jab what does it matter he's hitting
with the jab the flame corner the height
man I don't like the way that was you
know kind of handled but at the same
time max is great he'll be back I know
he's we're gonna run this fight back and
then of course the main event fight for
the US tomorrow who's made the champion
yes
welterweight against the former cuz he
gave up his belt
interim welcome attention colby coming
to fight this that's the one that came
with them the paint on his face yes
which way he came in after taking out
tyron woodley is his first title defense
it was calling him buzz government they
think what you will about Colby
Covington but the dude really does have
the goods in there it was a fantastic
fight I don't know what the scorecards
look like um okay
I honestly it was tight and I in that
fifth round until Huisman knocked him
down and finally finished him Covington
was winning that right that right
that I heard Kobe drug Abreu yeah he
popped them with a write that just
snapped his join to like it wouldn't
stick he fought the last two rounds with
a broken jaw again think what you will
about him magma
I think Kobe has the goods to hold up
today to the villain mantra I think more
than Connor
I think Connors not as more mouth to
skill trouble eaten at all Connor has
skill man just stop man like the dude or
anyone dimensional compared to Kobe yeah
but Connor one dimension is great Smitty
Smitty built a fire on a super chat he
said I just picked up a milk carton I
saw Chris Hart is missing maybe that
he'll blame you might be honest um TKO
fantastic spy all the way around both
fighters deserve bending of the knee so
shout out to def siga Oreo ice treat
brother shoutout to addict who did that
discriminate all his likes or Gabe
Awards watch it watch the reaction to
get the context also King bring the
smoke you saw you want to get dizzy
right now hold on one second shot out to
I okay hold on we got dizzy okay dizzy
eighty one with the two dots of chat
Sunday isn't the same 140 people looking
for Christopher hogshead play yeah
brother let me take yourself running
duck and hide baby don't look if you
personally are looking for Christopher I
want I want some into the bushes in that
chat right now if you are looking for
Christopher we need some into the bushes
in that chat salute Bobby
said I could never sing it on the on the
game award stream for self regulating
his f-bombs yo.hannes LBJ has to be
checked so when can we start calling
Phil Aurelius okay I thought is a very
very stringent stipulation for him to be
called Aurelius that you will achieve
that Orillia status and in our lifetime
and in the next two years maybe to be
honest with you maybe I launched
attention five not now I want people to
be aware that him gonna realest is like
equivalent to Goku go super Sam for no
no the instinct that that when he turned
blue that's Phil that's cool going the
ultra instinct okay this is it can't be
given that that's such a great analogy
because Jarrod's pretty much like
unstoppable go could go so traits say
you beat them at the end understand once
that game passes on PlayStation because
it's a conclusion that game pass will be
on that switch in some form of capacity
or once we achieve ultimate instinct
[ __ ] a really aesthetic big there's
a segue right now because how did Johnny
did B's already debuting new things
already of course you already know you
got the load of gravity straight to
gaming into himself this shinobi Lord
Cognito in the realm doing what we do
thank y'all for rockin out man we got a
lot of fun today I could get down on
browsers he said ultra instinct bill
shout out to my boy has a KA og dude you
gave already set the tool you notice a
so we out here at the Lords y'all know
y'all been rocking the shades and you
know we've already had you know filled
ominous you don't say but I think it's
time King I think it's time for that sig
that everybody's been waiting for you
know Rosie
everybody
did that for you did that for you that
is the question right up in the TSP
store I want you to see this man this is
a moment and if you join what I see
you're part of the realm you could put
the who did that for you mo g up right
now if you want to join right now hit
the join button and get a pill Dominic
Spencer and get there who did that for
you right now hot off the presses we
need some company we need to sometimes
you got to reflect on who brings you
these things in life to dig kijima saw
the series EXA said i bought the wrong
side while all that good stuff um and of
course on out of world still still yes
they got a little shine at the awards
and all that but I'm gonna get you to
the polar forgive all I didn't even get
a chance to say what I was playing but I
was I'm playing destiny and for all you
frauds out there hold on I want you to
hold this because destiny got the first
of water to evening me how a game that's
dead got it and tell me tell me how a
game that's dead just put out a good
content
there's just out of the day like this
besides Ubisoft games which have ungodly
life um we was just talking about that
isn't they they have ungodly waived and
unwavering ungodly life in their games
and destiny has the same amount of life
shoutout to all the pears shoutout to
the community shoutout to everybody that
keeps this game alive and will not let
it go to the bushes at any point you say
that to the hundred sixty people
watching right now
listen yeah cuz y'all want that smoke
baby you know comfort trust me you'll
get plenty of them and we've got to sort
of spirit mama said Lord I write for a
site filled with damned destiny fish Oh
Delilah HD $10 ooh yeah I am so loving
this energy who did that for you hashtag
t gree 30 2013 open who did that Jack
that's it so man we appreciate we do
something fun for y'all and all praises
to the kingdom king he designed that man
shout to grab the Garden of God's coming
through with everybody that's all King
the hands for me I just the hands for
you because he did it just like this you
know what it kind of looks like how it
looks like like that moment where you
get mad it's on you and you put up your
hands like what you doing let's go is so
monumental because you see the leg
spread because in that Dominus mode
grind your gears baby no because that's
how it started yeah alright shout out to
um it was a planet xbox because it was
the ILP and planet xbox collabo show and
yeah there was some things we said about
filling the room just like a
three-minute right you literally the
only thing you responded with that well
who did that for you xbox only begotten
son how we do it king hold on hold on
hold on please speaking Jamaican brother
he said I had a great time on crossfire
Friday night with Walcott oh thank you
but yo he let me tell you right now will
my hood right now in the community like
if you're not following him if you're
not subscribed to him please do is one
of the most positive people you
don't follow him just how he promotes
his podcast there hilarya he's
tremendous he's a pure gamer he's not
about the negativity please support our
brother woman thank you so much brother
and all you want to get the next one
addict yeah oh my gosh so we got a $2.00
super chat from pixel veggie who did
that for you looks like a Goku spear
bomb you know what you might be onto
something is the iron Lords podcast on
that spear bomb on Sony's head he looks
like that when he's making it but okay
we'll go with that are in the people
have spoken to the question if the
rumors regarding horizon zero dawn
having a PC release turn out to be true
how does this affect your view regarding
Sony first party exclusives moving
forward the winner of the three-way ILP
at 65% is this is the future of gaming
benefit Sony financially and more gamers
get to play coming in at second place
with 23% of the vote was I don't like
this direction so the first party should
remain exclusive group a covenant at
last place with a surprising 12% of the
vote was that I don't care until it's my
favorite so the exclusive group the man
with that will Lord what a week it is
been magneto hit me up he's like I need
you yes I need you an ILP this week
let's go I'm here man cuz we have a lot
to talk about I needed a week and a half
ago when they
did you put like the uh like like the
little card well you hit its ran off the
card you can't talk to me about Gary
scores once I use my trump card it was
over but you play ABARES but exciting
week what you could play you mean what I
haven't been playing ok listen
so jazz we did this whole thing for
charity right my first time ever playing
Pokemon yes raised like $700 going to
gamers outreach right um suffice to say
Pokemon enough for me and I felt like
it's a game made for 12 year olds its
robbed me of my joy video games wow wow
I cannot play that game for longer than
30 minutes without being bored out of my
mind and because of that I have no
desire to play anything else well you
know PC gamers are gonna be feeling that
boredom too when that game comes to PC
you agree with the poll that uh-oh
here's the thing here's the thing I know
it's coming it's not it's not a
prediction I already know okay and it's
not just horizon zero dawn oh it's quite
a lot of Sony first-party coming to PC
oh my god you listen Papa please look
look King wants to throw that sphere
balls let's toast beer pong we go get it
go right now I had to get read its
proper it's like this this is gonna be a
show so let's get to it obviously this
is a huge week you know say to power our
dreams power our dreams
you know and I don't agree with the name
but when they did the sad we was running
with that yeah we're gonna run with the
sex box
neither the sex box is a lot better than
sad box so shout - Oh Lord - singing so
you think when Sonny Ace or the ex was
like oh damn they got a fridge we got a
dumpster also shout outs of rain nice to
see with the solid inside no so we can't
get to it I mean obviously this is like
a huge week they the game Awards it's
probably one of the biggest weeks has
happened this year if not the best week
since 83 you know I'm saying so long you
know I want to break it down below diff
and I'm bad wait for Sony but we'll go
it's a great week for Sony it was a
fantastic week for fanboys I mean why
was a great week for Sony like I said we
had a lot of announcements here right we
had you know the reveal we had the name
you know saying we had Phil on stage at
the Game Awards you know I'm saying then
we had a game to talk about you guys
they're showcasing power stuff so I want
to break it down a little different and
I want to start off with the console
reveal itself the name you know I'm
saying the tech behind socks when you
take someone Lord ranks it's really why
he's here Cleveland we were itching we
were we couldn't stop talking to each
other two divs and I want to know paint
a picture ring like how was that whole
feeling for you when this whole thing
happened um incredible like I need set
it up because earlier there that day I
predicted they would do this yes you did
on xbox - I said they're going to reveal
the console and the name and people
people were like no no no no and I felt
it was happening man because I pieced
together a lot of the clues that they
were dropping around so and I did kind
of find a little interesting that all of
a sudden people trying to figure out the
name like the media is like out of
nowhere everyone the the media's trying
to figure out what the names gonna be
right yeah there was that the survivor
article that came out so I'm sitting
there watching it right and
was watching it when in a party with
like eight people three of them from
xbox and when Jeff started like doing
that little hype like oh you guys have
have a really high expectations world
premieres but then they're things that
happen you know what I'm like
oh my god this is this is it and I mean
I gotta forget you know I forget we're
in the realm I was about to use and I
knew I knew it was the reveal because
someone said be quiet and pay attention
mmm and I was like oh my god it's really
happening
so like immediately I'm like oh my god
this is this is this is scarlet this is
freakin scarlet and it's funny watching
like I I watch you guys's reactions so
later after YouTube what removed a
little bit yeah you know what's funny
man I got to work and I was like I want
to watch everyone's reaction I'm sitting
here bored and then I and then I click
cause you know how you know it like cuts
the beginning of it into the full videos
right there so I had to wait for that to
get done but when the full videos got
Richard they all got blocked every
single water for like five or six hours
I shot the l-boogie 20.7 Thank You L Oh
Xbox series X got people shook it
hashtag who did that follow you watched
our reaction to everybody's listening
amazing it's like what would you say
you're like show me you're terrified I
was dying man but I couldn't it was such
an aggressive move that Microsoft has
not made this entire generate that's
what me and Laura Cognito we're saying
that like this is a big deal because
it's not like them it's not like
basically turn the tables on PlayStation
and to go from to go from reacting to to
like being because this is the only part
I'm gonna be able to grab it from this
part right here okay
my brother is truly appreciated and I do
appreciate everything that y'all guys do
um first and foremost Randolph throws my
guy and he's not on with what he is
saying but if any of you guys have ever
started study 50 laws of power I wish I
could go out and get that book I want
you to study it if you got they got all
your TV show they got power so you can
study how to use the art of wall washing
listen phil has been using this ever
since he was working ever since he was
on the lowest pole to the highest plane
he has been an even keel quarterback at
all times yeah I've never seen him too
high you've never seen him too low he's
always been that quarterback that Tom
Brady's at Captain America right there
in pocket at all times and when seeing
this understood certainly the rest that
he was under before with different
regimes in charge now you guys got a
chance to see the regular Xbox come out
he wasn't pleased with that but as the
company dude as the dude toting the line
he had the support of going all the way
through when oh boy Donny got up out of
there the first thing that he did was he
revised those boxes but he had to work
in the constraints of those boxes right
he couldn't go and change the whole
format of how to box look so he had to
work with what he had this man has been
working with what he had forever mm-hmm
now that was up from a position of
weakness right so everybody saying Phil
is shaking hands and he's so nice and I
don't like how nice he is when you move
him through a wound full of snakes you
got to know how not to get bit pressured
to power to get to the table King
exactly so he finally got to the table
y'all saw him get to the table now that
he's at the table he has people that
support them because the team's message
has never been clearer and right you see
people understand what the branding is
and the message is this is remember
before y'all say all we don't understand
what the message is is too confusing you
have people talking on a turn
when everybody wasn't in lockstep their
lockstep now and you know what I wanted
like really point out that if you look
at one phil announced especially
hell-blade he's talking about you know
project series acts and he announces
hell-blade I don't think I've ever seen
him more confident in the entire year it
was it was the confidence he has when
it's not on a stage and I took I showed
you that picture when he acts those two
dudes out late from milk there was all
filled ominous has always been a good
speaker but like when he was speaking
that time it felt like his energy was
behind like he was on he was on that
stage and he's like yo move back to the
position of power where he's talking
from and everybody's confused at new
Phil this is not new Phil this is Phil
Dominus maxima spencer sir and exactly
who it's gonna be Aurelius cuz that is
definitely gonna happen but when you
start to dictate pace and soldier
exactly what up right now but the thing
is the thing is the series ex is his box
from the ground up thank you eat with
even with the 1x he had the image of the
one that he had to work with that right
had to work within those constraints
this is his box even though you
reimagined to make the X in the S it's
still not his platform it's not a
platform he's he's evolving it but it's
not his platform
this is his platform ground air about he
cares about function the form he told
them to make XY and Z this is the points
that we're trying to hit that's when you
working from power you understand and
then we can worry about the form on the
outside later right yeah it's a sexy box
it looks nice that's the sex I would
again there and it probably has to do
with the name to go with the X series
because I mean when the X came out in
2017 that was him and what he wanted for
the first time anchorman you can't be
talking like that scaring me
I almost almost pooped took my headset
off a jumped out of my womb you scared
you so good we got bad gay bigoted
billabong I got it let grande get his
bars off cuz Ram we got to get back to
the moment hands will be daggers with
the $2 super chair Xbox sex stands tall
and a wreck Osiris off we need the Jew
King this is not the last word of the
desk I am completely okay with you
saying let's go but let me bring it back
to RAM because ran you know you were
painting the emotional picture you were
painting I want to go back to the moment
give us everything going on through your
mind wow this is happening and I do want
to ask rant tube with 40 answers that
did you expect the hell-blade
announcement I did I did say in the show
that I thought there'd be a third game
an unannounced game that Microsoft would
show and I said I thought it could be a
ninja theories project so I figured why
not when they reveal the console I'm
like they're gonna like look we all know
what the talking point has been about
Xbox this Jen especially recently ever
since EXO 19 which one so what the one
the one about all the makers cartoony
games the most recent one because people
are starting to shy away from Xbox has
no games - okay they do but they're
cartoony right right though Phil takes
the lead right he takes the baton from
Sony basically jet head yo jump starts
or jumps a forward ahead of everybody
because that was we're sitting here
thinking all right early next year
Sony's gonna do a PlayStation five
meetings in February they're gonna show
it off Microsoft will you know come back
afterwards like they did but now Phil's
like screw that I'm dropping the box now
during the VGA s and it's gonna be the
talk of the town literally every they'll
be it'll be like think about this you
I didn't even care what happened in the
v-j sat there and I was just like
looking at people's reactions like it
completely over shed that whole event
and for since then it's been all people
can talk about right and now now the
question is is like will it look stupid
looks like a refrigerator and then the
other talking point is well grandma
she's gonna be so confused like oh my
god okay okay fine whatever right but
and then Phil he's like knowing and we
all know like okay the talking point
he's like alright we don't we only make
cartoony games they're only double-a
mm-hmm check out this and it's ninja
theories no game and it looks
ridiculously insane and all of a sudden
all the haters and whiny [ __ ] out
there and it's it's a one quick move
Phil domina Spencer played all the
critics and this is the type of feeling
I wanted to feel thank you after III you
know I thought EXO 19 was alright and
but like after III I was so disappointed
because I thought they missed the marks
so bad yes and then now I'm like okay I
think they know what they're doing they
have a plan in place clearly
mm-hm and I mean I've been saying this
for a while and people get on me for it
I've never been more excited for the
future of Xbox compare there's like yeah
well we need to compare today 2019
you're out to where Xbox was in 2012 a
year off from the 360 like the future
was a system built for Kinect and TV
watching instead of the Beast the
monster series X which is built to do
one thing and that's play video games
you notice on rim he was completely
clear when he said that it's like his
his message was so clear that he said
this is built for game this is built for
games
mm-hm and then you had Microsoft
flirting with
connected making that trash back then
and then and then like the studios now
you have 15 studios all making different
stuff no gimmick [ __ ] your chest and
and this is from all that stuff that you
had to endure and here and all this
other crap when you knew it wasn't true
but see I've known that this week ever
since that xbox showed that thing the
award show the Xbox show ever since the
Xbox show came on it was held doors on
Ward stuff there - um nobody's been
bothering you some people might comment
so I love I like the name online I mean
they screwed over the naming convention
with the 360 let's be honest I like the
fact that is just Xbox and I was trying
to explain it my video like listen the
name is Xbox Series X is the Titan is
the code oh and when Lockhart comes out
it'll be Series s and you remember
Cognito when me and dealer pulled you
pulled you aside for that destiny
intervention job yes yes dealer tell you
mean dealer told you la cartes real yes
but at that point in time
everybody's like la cartes canceled meet
me mean deal we're like no dude Lockhart
never was cancelled that's a little
inside info and incognito was like you
got serious and we're like dude the
information will come out eventually
that Lockhart is real and you know
dealers been saying that in videos for a
deal has been on wait time and I've been
saying in the podcast it's like it's
it's real and here you go series X no
power greater than actually you know
ugly that is the moniker for the most
powerful version I don't know what those
still name Lockhart oh my god no
nobody's greater than s no value greater
than s you know instead of so the series
actually have power your dreams serie
let's just call it series s power your
wallet I would I want to touch on one
thing for our past around the round
table
you know as far as what Rand said and I
whoa - no shelter to shelter jean-marc
Lewis with the - our super chat God fall
is destiny DLC your solve you want to
get that CJ Miller shout out to CJ
Miller with the $10 super chat there's a
lot of folks acting brand-new after that
I wanna I think Randy you touched on
something that's really important and a
lot of people are doing said like yo
yeah active Rando your zit or you know
for the Xbox fan base and I think what
you said had so much weight of the whole
generation right the whole generation as
far as what I consider magic moments
where you galvanize your base me and you
ran have had these conversations after
e3 you don't say in 2019 EXO and stuff
like that where they may have had good
displays if you look at it on paper what
they actually present it but they
actually never really appeased the
hardcore and I think what this did was
not only were they proactive right and
jumping ahead and very aggressive and
the key thing for me is it was such a
surprise like really outside of you
predicting right the majority did not
leak this no one got knew about it so it
had so much more of an impact and again
like you said Triple A experience right
mature tiger for a single player right
and the thing is because I got it right
people people are like oh you knew
sometimes I'll slightly like per say
it's my prediction but I already know
I'm never bidding with you sir I did not
know nobody told me and I I don't know
like I just it was such a the fact that
it didn't leak and this I mean look we
all know there no one was looking for
this leak no thought they were gonna
show that's they obviously told people
because aim stop or get GameSpot and IGN
had stuff up right away right away right
yes but I'm just saying like like even
look at like stay to play right Resident
Evil through that resident evil 3
announcement would have been massive if
it didn't leak were granted Sony leaked
of himself
because the PSN era but um this was
amazing because it didn't leak and
everybody was so surprised cuz then you
watch it he's like is what is this like
and you're like everyone's like cuz when
I was watching they were like people's
reactions because this Bioshock as soon
as they go into the water wouldn't yeah
you are like as a sex calm and I'm like
what the heck is that expose you don't
play XCOM don't mean that mine with 80
or less predictive that yours alright X
comes to three and Bioshock are both on
the water
thanks common things like wait a minute
this is a car then the car shows up and
you can see people's disappointments
because they're like a racing game but
an immediately switch to a soccer player
and you could see people are like wait a
minute
and then it's Master Chief and you think
to yourself the moment I saw Master
Chief dies when it started hitting me
that's that black monolith from 2001
Space Odyssey looking like a tower PC or
whatever you know you knew as soon as I
saw the thing I'm like they chose that
form factor for a reason and the reason
was I'm sure Mads can explain better
than any of us here yes because that
thing is a beast yes it's funny it's
funny because I know some people in the
community you know like give dealer a
lot of you know don't believe him or
give him a lot of crap but man he's kind
of spot on with a lot of videos I mean
he had that video come out basically
give him the specs then Wendell Central
said they heard the same stuff and now
Phil saying the same stuff it's like hmm
maybe you should pay attention to what a
lot of us mm-hmm
are saying because we know some stuff
it's a great time man I got cannot like
hell-blade we already know next-gen
games we got how blade we got ever wild
mm-hmm you got Halo infinite more to
come
I saw the during the game informer when
they were reacting to it he said that he
talked to Matt booty one of the guys and
he said you'll see what the the
initiatives game is gonna be like in a
few months
so I'm assuming that a reveal or
whatever like they're they're gonna be
hitting on all cylinders man they yeah
and you you know what I want to point
out to ran like the the the best thing I
could take from the from this video game
awards is like Phil isn't holding back
like Phil Thomas Spitzer like he came
out there and you know people keep
saying oh you know they're not gonna
announce anything Phil don't like
announcing stuff too far out and he came
out that he's like here's how Blake -
mm-hm
it's so like and that's what gave me a
lot of hope for especially you know an
event like III is cuz now everything's
on the table if he's willing to do he'll
play to know now shout this Cyrus
Berkeley til I Super Shot Tower of Power
so let's get if Lord is Lord Monson I
see you muted hopefully he's on musics I
want to get some tech breakdown for him
but while we're waiting for months lord
anchorman man I see in the building of
course game before tape I want to get
you in man like give me you put me
through all this month I see miles for a
second and I would get you get anchor ma
do you dare you your mics is up Lord to
give me that tech girls yeah yeah
creator of fancy-looking PlayStation
vids man I want to take you to it you
know me and you've been talking for a
while and I was here we talked about
what you're feeling on a reveal but I
also want your feeling from the
technical aspect right because me and
you we love to dive onto the hood what's
going on there you know because we're
hearing a lot of terms you know what I'm
saying and um I want you to break it
down man like tell me tell me what you
feel is okay so what might be my
feelings on there actually reveal let's
go first of all I didn't watch it live
which was very unfortunate because I
live in Poland
so it was like 2:30 a.m. for me to watch
it and I was actually wondering I was
like okay should I stay and should i
watch and stuff about like I had to go
obviously to work next day stuff so I
like you know what there's probably
nothing going to be interesting there so
and I woke up and like what the hell is
going on do you you know what's you know
what's funny was I actually like brought
my work home to watch the
goodbye though take us to the moment we
gotta get everybody's feeling what was
going through your mind man yeah and I
was like what the hell is it I mean
people are talking about new eggs I mean
I mean how long have I been sleeping for
a couple months
damn III just going through my like you
know I'm actually my wife was like kind
of like hey Matt I mean Marcin what's
going on right I mean like because I was
like sitting at the you know with my
phone in my head like like like like
basically like you know concentrate in
stuff right and um yeah I must I was
shocked and obviously then you know I
just went through like I didn't watch
the whole you know reveal I mean the
whole show I just wanted to like you
know watch the actual revealed so
obviously you know I kind of knew that
was going to what I what I am about to
see right I knew that going to reveal it
and stuff I was surprised because like
first of all the actual form factor rise
let's talk tech baskeball it's like the
first thing obviously I play on PC quite
a lot quite a lot as well and I was like
that's a nice-looking PC tower I so I
mean you know the form factor is like
you know I I guess it is a little bit
boring to me I guess they could done
something more to it right
but like I'm totally fine with because
people are kind of like some people are
concerned about where they're going to
put it ever ever write something where
we're concerned that they they won't be
able to write exactly so obviously that
debunked and stuff but hey man I mean
this thing is huge for our console Hey I
mean for PC it's like small [ __ ] PC
write much more occult oh it's it's it's
it's big and you know when you look at
it you it screams power right so I mean
like I I do like how it looks and stuff
well are you who are you - it is there
are you cool with the
you don't function over form so to speak
and then obviously we've got in a spat
specs and I wanted to talk touch about
the you know we've got good conformation
nvme SSD right we're talking about
controllers share back button they're
talking about that then with the seven
animated process so I want you to to get
down with that that tech like how
impressed were you with that okay well
it's obviously that was not in the
actual reveal right so like you know
after after I watch that after I saw the
magnificent trailer who obviously held
late to I love the first games though
and I mean like and this heavy metal
kind of song I mean music and stuff
right that was I mean I was kinda like
yeah hopefully it's the kind of game I
play with the lights on I mean no I
don't go yeah I was this trailer I watch
this trailer like 15 times at least that
day but obviously then the Phills Benson
posted this blog right and this a very
important thing in this blog post right
obviously if they confirm that is then
based so I'm talking about CPU they
obviously come from the nvme which is
very fast SSD and stuff right I'm not
sure where I read that but they somebody
was saying that it's going to offer up
to two gigabytes of bandwidth right so
just to give you a comparison like a
standard hard drive which you may
actually find in your PC or Xbox for
example right offers and like prefer in
terms of bandwidth it it offers around
like a hundred megabytes per second
right read reason right right
I mean some some are a little bit faster
some are a little bit slower but you
know it's just on average 100 100 100
megabytes so this nvme apparently it
over two maybe even three gigabytes
right oh that they claim that you heard
from phil spencer or somebody else for
Microsoft saying that the storage is
going to be 40 times faster Wow well
possible Wow okay
a second that the the importance of nvme
you know I'm saying which with the SSD
as far as your boot Thompson and also
the functionality are talking about and
today talking about multiple games y'all
having being able to come back from a
resume straight not just one yeah and
the funny thing about that is I was
listening to shout out to be Gee Bee
Gees were impressions and he actually
brought that bad SSD up and he's like I
don't think they'll be using that he
said let me look that up he's like wow
they they really not play they're using
that too mm-hmm so from a violation
you can shout out to the over 220 to 225
so obviously like if we took it about
the differences between you know current
generation and next generation like each
generation offers some sort of like
performance boost in terms of like GPU
CPU whatever right but the actual
storage was always pretty much the same
if you compare the storage like I mean
original Xbox had a hard drive it's
probably offered like maybe half of that
it was you know like but it offered
maybe half of the speed like of the
current hard rice made right so
obviously you know that the the
differences between like OG xbox Xbox
360 and Xbox one hard drives are not
three not that huge
right but now we are getting like 40
times faster you know store it right
unless you so but obviously like storage
is fine cool right I don't mind waiting
couple of seconds for like for our game
to load right but what really got me
excited is the fact that in this blog
post both pensa talks about Mariah
right shade yes and okay so when they
announced scarlet at e3
they obviously confirm their hardware
accelerated rate racing now if somebody
is following what AMD is doing and
obviously aim DS working with Microsoft
you know on the actual GPU and CPU side
of things
and current current Navi GPUs are not
supporting ray-tracing are in hardware
accelerated rate race really write this
thing this feature is going to be
officially supported and not has been
call already confirmed in the next
second generation of our DNA and second
generation of you right
which us as the latest reports say
probably going to be announced in the
next couple of weeks I mean probably CES
don't mean that
so lychee like two three weeks to three
weeks in the access that's coming yes so
so just just the fact alone that
Scarlett will be supporting hardware X
of that rate racing bang then you know
many people including myself
well basic saying okay so does it mean
that Scarlett is going to be using our
DNA 2.0 right second-generation our DNA
and I will tell you why it's so
important in a second break them so now
we're actually getting another feature
that is supported only by our DNA 2.0
which is variable right shading right
and they say patented he feels it yeah
but that doesn't mean much this week
yeah I mean maybe they've got their own
way of using it on on the serial sex
right but like this is on a new this is
not a new technology NVIDIA has been
used has been actually using it for a
while noting not many gains actually
supported but like you know once
consoles get it I mean that's probably
going to be different story right so so
now we've got two features ray tracing
harder accelerated ray tracing and
variable ray shading that ours are
supposed to be supported only on Navi
big navvy as people call it right so our
DNA 2.0 right and so I mean like I mean
is it is it I mean like you know add one
to one it's well you know where it leads
I mean do what we do
yeah I mean it's kind of like obviously
this this is not our own official
confirmation of Scarlett using our DNA
to point 0 but it looks but it looks
like that's going to be case
and now let's talk about power whoo so
the current our DNA is not the most
efficient or microarchitecture the
problem is that you know it draws a lot
of power so if you draw a lot of powers
you will produce a lot of heat yes well
obviously you know that that may lead to
issues right like you know console
something like jumbo jet so I mean that
that may be an indication that that ship
is going to be right right that's going
to be a lot of heat and that needs to be
obviously pull out of the pool from the
actual box now what's interesting about
our DNA - and obviously that has not
been efficient conference because you
know there's no benchmarks yet but our
DNA 2.0 is supposed to it that's going
to be produced on improved 7 nanometers
process which should be cheaper to
produce because current 700 meters
process is pretty acts still acts pretty
still expensive you know believe it or
not so a 7 on meters plus UV process
apparently is cheaper right so they we
know that's so it makes sense to use it
right another thing it it offers 20%
reduction in the transistor density
right so basically you can put more
stuff on the same area right and we know
that those chips what I mean
when tsmc for example produces achieve
AMD or Microsoft doesn't pay them for
features but they pay them for for the
actual size of the chip right
so the bigger chip the bigger chip is
the more you have to pay but when you
have a new technology that allows you to
put the more transistors on the same
size of jabe well you get basically
extra performance I should perform so
yeah so I mean like because like if a
week ago if you told me that next-gen
consoles
probably going to be 12 tariffs I would
say I mean now that's not going to
happen right right I mean I really
really because like everybody let's be
the consensus was that this was you know
pump the brakes right as far as a
console having that level of performance
right but now based on what you're
saying that based on this tech that's
inside and now we're discovering you
know are you you basically saying that
this is could possibly reach or shout
the $2 super chat it's about as tall as
Xbox one expand and up
okay people in the building I'm gonna
let you go finish up Maz and I gotta get
the other guys yeah so just one thing so
basically if Microsoft is really going
to use our DNA 2.0 it's really possible
that next-gen consoles going to be might
be at my tech it end up with well
teraflops GPU and it should be totally
fine in terms of like you know power
draw and the heat dissipation everything
right and just the fact alone that you
know Microsoft officially confirmed that
they they will have hardware accelerated
rate racing and arrival rate shading on
that chip means that they probably going
to be using our DNA 2.0 which is huge
right so yeah as usual at the Masters I
do I do have a question real quick real
quick for from your technical standpoint
try to give me an estimate of your shot
in the dark how much you think this
thing's gonna cause the price hold on
over I got that I got you
I gotta get we got Forte we got kids
moving the row well we can't really we
can't go into their their forms of this
until we know the prey oh we go get cuz
I got a specific topics what about now
kid kiss move are you in a building sir
I am here listen you go back and you
know you are the king of react so I
gotta give you credit for actually shout
that's not a reaction but I got it no I
thought I thought you're gonna die from
like an aneurysm or something man like
you barely breathing with me now smooth
I consider you the king of reactions I
consider you I love watching you do some
live whether it's a difficult game or
what happened so I need to know you
can't get excited if he falls out of
chairs you're like like bro game awards
put me through your mindset what's
happening yo here's the thing right I
was getting bummed out right because I
was like you know I was coming to the
facts a deaf stranding was gonna sweep
you know some attorneys can make your
award so it was like whatever and then
the games because remember it was a they
revealed a couple things first but they
weren't like big deals like whatever you
know I mean like I didn't care for the
reveals and then Jeff Keeley had got
this smirk on his face
and I'm like hmm what it's like what is
he like we found just Randy some some
like bull crap like indie game we never
heard of that's gonna be the big
surprise so I'll tell you what happened
so when a trailer start coming right
honestly I thought was gonna be some
death training update right no no Chima
marriage when the talking started I
thought it was a Bioshock related you
know in the water okay alright this
could be exciting for people um and so
then the car came no no no when a car
came right I thought it was like oh what
what racing game was been like we've
been waiting for for a long time that we
haven't had in a long time I'm like is
this like burnout or some [ __ ]
like maybe for now game and then the
soccer player comes this mashup and the
mic is then Master Chief in like I'm
like what's going noise just like a game
pass for like I clowder it likes like
now I'm thinking I'm thinking the Xbox
oh I'm not thinking cos I'm thinking
like iCloud like a bit like official
like hey this is my then everything
shapes it to a cube in my heart drop I
was about 15 seconds ahead of everybody
that I was watching the stream because I
was using the glory they were they were
legitly telling him to shut up
why
I was watching on the glorious mixer
they were watching on the you know -
delayed YouTube it lights turned blue
cube before even turned black I started
screaming oh man it got worse when he
stuck with me now to the point where my
phone as you start tweeting bull stuff I
like awesome
pre-order now you know what sucks when
he hit me up like 30 minutes before
Ferrari action because I think he was
gonna get into somebody's reaction my
exciting I was feeling lazy items like
on flight I'm not a fan of the game
Awards like that so I didn't feel like
it was worth different bucks is this I
was checking to see who's doing the live
reaction that I could jump in so I end
up jumping in works I would have loved
to edge up the Oscars yo I'll tell you
um I'm like at this point I'm super
excited because this came as a complete
total shock in the crazy thing is I was
I was actually upset because I missed
Xbox - like I usually know I missed it
that more so I didn't I didn't get to
hear ran call it out at the end of the
day was better for you because it turned
out to be better for me
but I felt like the one Xbox Tupac guys
I miss right and that's how I know I had
a bad day um so it happened and then
feels mr. come on stage and I'm just
like it was so bad that I didn't even
care
member yo.hannes core I didn't know for
the longest time you can mute everybody
if you want to hear them right so happy
to add that this court muted after a
while just to listen to what those ones
were saying and then the hell-blade
thing coming and I'm like yo I'm in
total shock into the point after that
was over I could not pay attention to
the rest of the being choked it was kind
of a distraction we couldn't believe
what just happened
so it's been like at that point the
minute that has stopped right I could
care less what have on what I get if
destiny would have swept the rest of the
show you wouldn't have heard anything
fake you know that that's funny because
I said the same thing I was like I was a
little card you know they kitty vote
that strany can win I'm good I'm good so
it was just like super excited so and
not just been like monitor excited over
like the last 48 hours and then I
finally had the time to check out the
other cuz I knew there was a lot of
people reacting the answer now so you
know let me check out I learn something
I'm gonna I want to see what happy like
during that moment I like fast forwarded
just to write to that Jeff Huey part
long flight Louis you ass and
everybody's giving her this dude and it
going off I was when they announced that
called soul I was speechless
why didn't I was just like I'm sitting
like in the time it registered he
announced um he now exhale played like I
wasn't in I was like they're not doing
this they're not announcing this at the
video game award it's very believable
Emily I'll be shout to Forte who's in
here shout out the boomstick Excel I
mean we we were all floored I just got a
trance with real quick cuz I know for
kid you got a lot I gotta ask you some
other questions - we got a big show but
I want to switch just for a second
because we I think we got the reveal but
I want to switch also to down obviously
price you know skews
and confusion because you know there's a
lot going on you know the Twitter
streets are hot you know obviously the
name you got Xbox series X we got all
that stuff popping you know I'm saying
and um I definitely want to get them in
because especially you for tape because
I'm gonna put your business up obviously
work in game retail you deal a lot with
that and um the talk that we're hearing
is obviously we know the name is very
similar right Xbox series X that we
already have an xbox one X you never say
so people are saying yo this is gonna
cause confusion a lot of people are
gonna go to retail and they're not gonna
be able to know what to buy you know and
this could cause problems it was a bad
mistake you know a Microsoft so I want
to bring it to you for telling this
question like the question I have for
you is being that you work in retail the
question I have is like when little
Timmy sends mom where's grandma to go
get you know a console you know is it a
situation based on your personal
experience right cuz you deal you deal
with multiple you know different outlets
around retail outlets you know that are
you seeing like high return rates for
people who purchase a system and it's
the incorrect system because they didn't
have the information or is this
something that's overblown like where do
you sit with this what's it this is the
most overblown thing I've ever seen in
my life it's like if okay so just a
little behind the scenes if we ever
return an item it gives us an option to
pick why is being returned and incorrect
version or wrong SKU is one of those and
they do give us a report on what those
are and I'm just trying to fathom in my
mind
little Timmy Senate mom into a store to
say hey I want to get an Xbox serious ex
well I can see how I could get be
confused with a regular Xbox and mom
come in there and see it but if they
come into the store and say hey I want
to get that new Xbox that they're
talking about first of all the X is 2 3
years old at that point so it's not new
it is second of all there's a price
disparity in that price what person is
literally gonna walk into a store and
just pay 700 $600 for a system in that I
don't want to hear that $700 hey I am
I'm king of that $600 price point I'm in
- oh no we were just talking it's seven
seven hundred could be a realistic thing
man but $600 I think that's on the title
thing antique cars could be $6.99 but I
all think that it's more of a the
confusion is gonna be more for people
trying to train their associates on
actually talking about discs used in
customers walking into the store buying
it because I'm sorry I'm gonna form yes
I'm gonna ask questions about something
that has a two to three hundred dollar
price disparity I know me you again a
very contentious topic it's very very
vocal but it's very tight it's very late
this day so my question make it like you
know what about the people who say look
this is different from folks this is not
like cars and monitors you know I'm
saying this is a console and people
you'd be surprised at the common you
know full casual doesn't know and they
you know could buy the incorrect thing
what do they think today the floor is
yours anchorman I'm listening so I will
first and foremost say this I'm sure
Forte will back me up on saying we got a
super chat oh you shout that down super
scheppers what about little DeAndre
though the fake outrage you get perfect
I miss them I'm missing please
we got a $2.00 super chat from perfect
Shogun I had the same reaction as smooth
I was yelling yes sorry that we missed
that sorry what was that getting so my
whole thing is that literally in a
worst-case scenario let's say we're not
talking about like okay headsets where
there's like 30 different things and
nobody knows anything about headsets
no-one's ever and it's like I really
don't know the difference between all
these but there's like a $5 $10
difference on every single headset that
I have about here like we don't know the
difference and there's no point
pretending that it's even remotely close
the same here you only have like maybe
three options and every single time you
go down that list all you're gonna ask
is yeah is this the latest thing
yes or no if it's not the latest thing
when I we don't even care at that point
if you're asking if you're asking for
the latest hardware there's only two
options like and you're gonna ask
yourself price or power right and at
that point there's really no point of
even arguing that mm-hmm oh this is
confusing and we've already set the
establishment and I firmly believe that
Lockhart will be called series s okay
and I think it's gonna be quite gonna
make it just like the Xbox one s
everything white so it's really gonna be
you want the white one or the black one
right so you have more of a color
distinction
it's literally you're either sitting it
I don't I don't honestly don't believe
because we always use the same example
of Oh little Timmy's of sending his mom
out to go get him a Christmas present
he's not going with her and she's like I
don't know the difference is whatever
just picks up we always assume that's
always the hypothetical scenario right
I'm talking about regular Joe Schmo
going out there was Leo 20 30 years old
he knows what he's getting anyway right
so we're not talking about that snare
we're talking about Oh an uninformed
person who doesn't know anything about
video games being sent to go buy
something for someone else
either a little tummy knows exactly what
he wants and it's going to say mommy I
want the Xbox Series X right and it's
gonna use that term specifically and
that's it but let this little mom or mom
doesn't care for the sake of fairness
you know again we have to admit Xbox
series X sounds like Xbox one X so nah
man all right back to you Reggie
well before table my question is like
okay you know do we still have to say
the onus is on Microsoft to get the
messaging correct that they still like
detail to you guys like they have to be
very informed that someone doesn't buy
the incorrect system based on the names
being kind of similar a king will you
get those last two super chats real
quick before we move on okay you want me
to use my blind eyes lock hardwood
we out holiday 2020 um I beg to differ
but hey you know and then we got
darkness and be good job then be good
job B so therefore it's a so so explain
to me why that you don't think that's
addition so I will tell you this I will
agree with your one thing the marketing
that Microsoft does on the back end will
significantly help right with this um
issues but I just think overall it comes
down it really just comes down to people
know what they what you know most of
these people buy stuff offline anyway so
you know when you when this system
releases its gonna be the number one
reserved or sole gain system on Amazon
so it's not like people are gonna make a
real big distinction and probably some
problem with that I just think overall
it really just comes down like he just
said right you know they come into the
store they have it directed of what they
want to get that print that mother or
father or brother whoever is buying is
gonna ask questions and I always equated
like the big thing I always tell people
now when it comes to the difference
between the X and s is now what's the
difference uh well do you want a four
cylinder or do you want to eight
cylinder with a finish re because I
literally just dumb it down to what most
people can understand and then if they
do when they say they say oh okay so
it's basically just a faster more
prettier and more up scalable system I
don't even have to tell them that they
kind of know that it's the analogy
itself right and also the other scenario
that I always see these about say okay
there's sin and mom or dad at a mom dad
mom dad doesn't care about little Timmy
they're just getting them something
there's just something to shut them up
right and they say okay I just wanna
give you me the Xbox and as a really
gonna say like okay do you want the
latest thing or do what the or something
else it's alright well I want ya sure
the latest a whatever the new Xbox is is
alright cool well we got one that's like
five hundred six hundred dollars it's
the most powerful one or we got one
that's a little bit cheaper you could
use that one too I was your only one and
they're gonna make a decision right then
and there because they don't really care
yes you poetic Exodus
with the father switch a shout-out to
the Justice League / Avengers panel hate
that I gotta go to work
we'll catch the rest later from NYT my
son sent me a screenshot of what he
wanted for Christmas
hashtag little Timmy's own app that's
what I want to bring up like look well
at the end of the day like we got to sit
stop acting like casuals like the
dumbest human beings walking around like
most of them are oh you mean to tell me
it's like I said on Twitter that someone
will Google what's the hardest part
around the area to go eat but they won't
be told me to do this I don't care
anymore just do it without at least
looking and see what it is all this fake
talk is trash this is just fake talk
let's go um you know um gamey Forte
understands that one there won't be no
X's and s's in a store facts facts um so
this is what's gonna happen Microsoft is
gonna stock up these stores with the new
systems and new systems is where game
stops and these retailers make their
money they're not going to be sitting
there selling old systems you know
systems will probably fall out of
production because that's not what
they're trying to push forward you
understand I do know that they're gonna
run out of the stock they're gonna sell
off the stock or whatever the stock is
the same way that PlayStation is selling
off all VR units the same way Nintendo
sold off all switch units for these
units will be sold out they will go out
later and earlier now and then later on
in the year when those two skills is out
for the white one and the black one
that's going to be the only question
when you go inside the store you know do
you uh how much are you spending first
of all this the price disparity is going
to be enough and alone to make a parents
say no he didn't do this well this year
so well so why do you care which unit
gets old
by the way that's another thing that you
know I think people really the only
really people buying the Anaconda
version of this is the people who know
what the Anaconda is so is it like
people that are on this panel you know
the people that are what the product is
but some people that 4k and 8k
televisions those are the premium people
that are getting this now I do want a la
carte for the television I have
downstairs is the premium 1080p
television and I don't see nobody buying
no no TV that I paid $5,000 for at 1080p
so I'm stuck with this television but
I'm gonna put that lock hard on it I'm
gonna get the best I can get out of it
so it's this is that there's something
else that's more important and this is
the part we have not talked about these
systems are access points to an
ecosystem the ecosystem is the most
important aspect of this entire thing
and a new generation is a jumping on
point for a lot of different people and
what these systems these are these are
just access points it's how do you want
to access your library of games in this
generation that we are currently in
right now we're about to transition over
to I believe was the start of the
ecosystem more than anything else
Lauren let me get random because I
haven't got a chance to talk to you
about this specific subject then I get
solved after which is you know there's a
lot of talk again people are saying you
know this could be a confusing thing for
Microsoft like where do you stand on
this thing with the marketing and the
whole naming conventions it's on
Microsoft to market it correctly it's
one of the areas that they have been
lacking this entire generation is
messaging and marketing but like I've
been saying since we heard anaconda and
lockhardt were thing back in 2018 that
come holiday 2020 there won't be Xbox
one X's on Microsoft is going to
discontinue that console because it
really doesn't serve a purpose anymore
Lockhart is better in every way than the
X and it will be cheaper than it so
it'll basically replace it and you'll
have Series X you'll have
whatever they're gonna call Lockhart's
series ass and then you'll have the sad
just saying I'm just saying like it's
it's not it's not that hard to kind of
figure out exactly what Microsoft's
going here so I don't really see a
scenario where someone goes the store
and there's like an ex really to be
bought besides a used version of it at
Gamestop that's gonna be discontinued
plain and simple
I've been saying that for since 2018 so
I don't think really think people will
get confused now I mean it's not like
straightforward like PlayStation 5 is
Ryan let's be honest right but I like
the idea that it's just Xbox it's just
like this is the new one series X is the
model but my anchor man's right it's all
about the ecosystem Phil said he doesn't
I mean Phil still got heat when he said
he doesn't have to sell you a console
right or a type of console it's like we
put our games on PC Windows 10 you could
enjoy the games there they're bringing
all their games to mobile if you want to
play a mobile or iPad you can do it
there right if you want to play it on
old gen you can do it you want to play
it on new gen you can do it doesn't
matter to them right you know so it's
just it's just an entry point to get
into the Xbox ecosystem and yeah I mean
I don't like I don't know like it's the
fact that the thing we're talking about
now is the name I just feel like okay
well I guess we're the this is like the
best-case scenario like if that's all
you gotta say is like well the names bad
then you know you've done right I do
have a quick question for you right like
when you first saw that box did you
think that is gonna be an issue
well you know the first time you saw it
pop up you know the little mystery they
come up and you saw you know the actual
structure of the new no because me mean
dealer had been talking back and forth
about you know cuz we he both hear
things from different people right and
we'll like bounce ideas off to another
and me and him have been hearing for a
long time that this system is insanely
powerful right twelve tariffs all the
stuff that basically got leaked we'd
known for a long time
and we kept on coming back and be like
do
how are they going to build a box for
this you're talking about a system
that's gonna draw a lot of power that's
gonna create a lot of heat and we just
is like I don't know and then when you
see the box you realize oh they did that
for a reason and then the game the
GameSpot interview and Phil was like
these are what this is what we want to
achieve build me a box and that
basically they said this is what we need
to make instead of trying to fit the
components into a visually pleasing
console they're like this is what you
need for something that's not gonna
overheat it that's gonna have enough air
flow and ventilation to you know get the
heat out or whatever so like yeah it
made sense when I saw it you know when I
first saw that like I didn't mind the
way look but I thought there'd be a lot
of issues with a lot of other people and
for the most part like in this community
in the industry like I have I see very
few people saying they don't like the
design positive reception to toss a
trophy mr. blow no one was confused on
Black Friday now where where they know
where they I want to get our salt man
cuz again solve you work with us live I
haven't had a chance to talk to you you
knows it and I need your whole feeling
this thing and then I move with the King
right after that like the Lord you the
two laws will we're missing and I get a
chance to really build with on this
whole what's funny is like when we were
waiting when we has those technical
difficulties I was asking them there
because I haven't talked to them yeah
again I had to jump in the chat when I
saw it and I'd the first thing I said I
mean one of the first when we were at e3
and we and we gave are like a post Xbox
conference uh thoughts with the first
thing he said was like I think they
dropped they dropped the ball I didn't
drop the mic they didn't drop the ball
and the first thing I put in the chat
after this was that's how you drop the
mic that's what you you come out there
and I've always said III is is the Super
Bowl of gaming right everybody the eyes
of the gaming world on III but at the
same time there is so much at e3 that if
if you're not a gamer that's interested
in everything you're probably not paying
attention to everything you're paying
attention to the stuff you care about
the game Awards is something that all of
gaming at this point is watching because
they want to see the reveal
they care less about the awards but they
definitely want to see the reveals so it
was the ideal place to do we just never
thought about all the talk with des
[ __ ] potentially winning game of the
year brought even more people to see it
yeah so it was it was the smartest move
imaginable to do who then was a field
Dominus move also midfield Dominus Mook
antsy Keeley's face how he was a excited
that it didn't leak and how he was just
antsy to get I get it get to it right
um it was absolutely to me I'd my jaw
dropped my jaw dropped and when I when I
saw the box I said this I loved it from
the beginning because it screams power
ring the industrial design you look at
it and it's like and the moment the name
came up it says Series X I said a it
gives them the opportunity to add
whatever other letter to that moniker to
the series whatever so I do believe
Lockhart it will be called series s that
makes the most sense um I just think the
Box screams power they we need to give
you what we're gonna give you we cannot
put in a rail box and I think there's
gonna be a lot of talk about how the
PlayStation looks when they finally do
reveal it right and and how that power
compares right and you know and that
goes into my feelings on the possibility
of a 599 price point also just one one
brief thing to the way it looks
different like it looks drastically
different from all the other consoles
let's say literally worst-case scenario
how could you be confused and I and I I
was one point last week they was talking
about confusing with both of them out
aid that one factor I mean you have to
be blind right
that's how power and and also the price
point thing looking at it that's all I
want you to promote this
Gaming every time someone comes in there
for this on what you said oh you want
the Tower of Power
whatever the Lockhart is will recall I
think that makes sense to differentiate
them and I that price point I'm gonna be
honest with you I don't know if I think
it's six doing this I don't I think that
Lockhart I've always said the Lockhart
is the most interesting aspect of this
to me because I think it's one it's a
console there's going to be a paragon of
amazing sort of like engineering right I
think they're gonna get a lot of power
out of that little box and I think in to
you for $400 no and I think I think the
reason that you know the PlayStation
might not be able to achieve this is
because the design because they were
willing to go out of the box and make it
know the station is willing to give you
a big lumpy box that that's that's what
I'm saying like because they're willing
to go against the the drawer again man I
forgot that whatever agrestic ray you
know because they're willing to do that
they might be able to give you a
stronger Boston PlayStation I don't know
the design and that design ethos for
PlayStation always been sleek has always
been so it'd be weird to see a big box
from that's not true no but if you think
about it if you think about it I said
this at I think in my stream where I
said I said if the PlayStation 5 is
going to be remotely close and power to
be the series of eggs then there's gonna
be an ugly console it has to be unless
cuz like places should make good looking
small consoles and I felt like excellent
Microsoft did the best they can do with
like building around near power because
they're usually been first new
generation consoles come out they
typically bake right right because they
don't know you know I don't slim down as
a generation gold yeah so I'm like if
the PlayStation this is the last
powerful PlayStation was big right it
appears three it was yes I expected
these these are gonna make you look like
that that um Swiffer jet-vac
a guy's a kid or is gonna be something
like Simba I don't I don't see it being
the bedpan yeah oh boy I gotta get as a
king your highness they have been asking
the round let me get my popcorn
when can we hear from the king
they said you called it they showed the
pictures from from past game Awards
would film Dominus Spencer in the center
and they want to know how you feel and
also I feel about the hell-blade reveal
you know Lord King the floor is yours I
can't stand award shows mm-hmm right all
right so looking when you start to look
at the map you start to look at the map
of how everything is to go forward right
and you got to look at how phil was
positioned from the beginning
so everything was climbing forward you
know he had to climb forward and first
things and first and foremost he said
okay if we're gonna be known as a 4k
machine as before Cain every box right
even the weaker box the weaker box was
able to do 4k blu-ray all right so he
was putting his stamp going along the
way the biggest stamp is game past
because that is allowing you to make
money without giving anything honestly
like we're not given anything physical
that's a magician that's a trick he's
tricking you by giving you something
getting money back for something that
normally teachers get physically but now
you're getting it you know like it's
software's like the cloud right the
power to cloud so now that you got the
cloud working now they're moving on all
cylinders let's go to e3 when we went to
e3 yeah we walked away from e3 and I
shake his hand I'm and I'm I'm keep it
real he was like what did you think and
I said this is not the time for me to
talk to you about that you know I was
here to give you your shirt I was hit
you know to bend the knee to the leader
in charge sometimes you may not
have the same viewpoint as your leader
sometimes you may want your leader to go
for the jugular but and knowing these
powers these laws you have to understand
you always move from a position of
strength and not a position of weakness
so what he was setting up at the e3 he
was giving you the games that we have
for this year coming right that right
right now moving on to EXO 19mm I
thought that was a very solid EXO for
the first time in a long time I walked
away from it like I was really pleased
with the stuff that they had they're not
the majority of the stuff was for me but
the majority of the stuff that was there
was good fresh and you see the direction
and it wasn't bogged down with all the
same crap what a good leader does is
they were moved all the bad talking
points he's been removing all the bad
talking points PlayStation can't talk
about power they no longer have 4k in a
box they did some dynamic stuff so
little by little they have been taking
away your complaints and your little
gripes cuz if you don't think he's
looking at Twitter and listening to you
run your mouth he they're poking the
bear so long okay now the bear got up
and smack the hello when when when that
happened when that moment happened I
said now's the time when I so what
you're saying is hibernation over the
Bears up and moving around
I said not I gonna run duck and hide
because my man is on his squid you ever
saw Muhammad Ali when he's in his prime
when he was dancing when he was boxing
the brakes off of somebody and he's
moving he was pop pop popping you and
you didn't get it at that moment but
when the hell blades Oh showed up that's
when he cracks your forehead and you
fell to the floor he had to bend that
knee this is the this is the part where
you guys got on my timeline I was
talking to me it was quite easy but
people were mad quiet they were mad
quiet they don't bother me that way from
me they were on your face for like three
days like on like constantly and the
moment that video game awards they're
like yo I'm leaving I'm out of here I'm
in front of the world mmm but you know
what you know what added insult to
injury what Jeff Keeley gave him that
yeah cuz you know what came up right out
of the hell-blade trailer PlayStation 4
Pro noted jury after that they now it's
the launch teller going to Epic Games
tell me about the swag like was the
energy different cuz oh okay she was
different
no I don't see no no his energy is
always the same he always has that smirk
I'm finishing you talk but you just
don't know it like you're being finished
off like where's Reggie yet right now
here in Honolulu someplace alright
where's the other dudes act from Sony
like the changeable head to Hydra he
ain't even really tweeted Godzilla in
this Hydra Rosa down was it last year
they had all three of them on stage this
is the people who are in compliance what
we do is we see all the people that's
willing to play ball and speaking of
playing ball we're gonna talk about that
too but all the people that's willing to
play ball you can stay and food is
plentiful for you see him when Phil went
out on stage of stomp to eat curb stomp
shoe because what he did was he put you
in a position let me tell you what the
fifty laws of powers just did to you go
he put you in a position to let you
understand that now I'm dictating pace
you can't keep up financially your
pockets are weak so I'm telling you and
this is this is the difference between
somebody that's real as somebody that's
fake you claim use the fastest but you
have to take that down booboo you have
to take that down you know what happened
well if you go to Microsoft joint
fastest and most powerful down I feel
you shout to Forte with the social
ballot in the sake of fairness the
argument could be made that film mail
bust early and allow PS 5 now to recoup
they try to counter like what does
Microsoft have to do for that I mean we
know piaf are becoming more powerful it
is the Lockhart the secret weapon to
marketing I three months last three
months they have been on their ball
everything that has they have been every
time PlayStation announces something
they're already ready to go on title
goose keycode a PlayStation 4 game past
early nope so he's no king listen listen
if their petty they petty would have
been announced already they petty they
put guard fallout nobody King member
remember last week you know what the
narrator was it was scarlet deaf kids
aren't ready they're behind gems are
upset yeah and now you see yeah yeah
usually Sony's extremely reactive like
so Microsoft does something they do
something to like kind of like stop the
cloud a little bit but Saudis been quiet
quiet and shut out the Kevin Hart
forgiving me that he wasn't ready he was
not ready like Sony said they said what
okay thank I know game played oh you
know the only other time I've seen Sony
this quiet and it seems like they they
did they it's not that like they're
scared or anything they're just they
they don't know what to say is when
backwards-compatible
he was analysis I understand that but
again just again just for
competitiveness you gotta set up the new
member to shout out a new member to the
round okay all right let's see you gotta
file a super chat get that awesome
hey as a new member to the round thank
you so much sir and shout out to key up
901 with the chat competition is good at
Microsoft in my opinion is hitting
gamers in all fronts first party console
power cloud and PC they are everywhere
one thing about the counter with Sony's
ribbo the Sony came back real quick
because you saw God fall very fast
looking beautiful yes and it's a
PlayStation 5 and PC yes so now you're
doing what now you're doing Microsoft
moves no whiz distain energy for that
game not being exclusive only to play in
the fire and it's like I was talking to
Laura cogito Kate could you not agree
that like Microsoft already had that
face were their fans you know okay
stuffs going to PC we accept that now it
seems like Sony has to go through that
now because it seems like you know they
lied to the consumer the first game the
day now it's officially on the PS 5 is
coming at big games don't think that's I
don't think that's gonna stop
and I got to get Randall a question but
it's like I said like you know I'm not
saying every game is gonna come to PC
but it seems like right now because
obviously the whole horizon zero dawn
thing now this new game is coming to
it's going to be coming to PC and it's
gonna be a long shot for the playstation
5 so if you see this trade continue I
feel like that might hurt them coming
next year because our fans aren't used
to that you know what I like the most
about the reveal I'll take his eye I
really got to say what really shocked me
the biggest shock out of all of that the
reveal not the power not the form I feel
on stage with the power sure powering yo
dreams none of that
cuz his shirts are always K watch his
shirts but the share button yeah I like
[Music]
300 people definitely at that like
button to take over the weights over
give a shout to one person Jim Ryan with
place he's going right in line with Phil
Spencer said alright yeah I guess you
were right sir we should come on over to
PC as well
it's amazing how quick things turn
around
anything Jim Ryan is a good guy one
thing to to everyone this generation was
stuck it out yeah we're all these people
who jumped in and they sat here and
waiting mostly people on this panel and
a lot of other people too I've been real
consistent and I keep their head
positive influence in this community for
Xbox everybody else thank you to the
people who are now looking to flip back
we don't want you we don't want you
unless you are willing to keep up that
same love for place because I don't want
people to be disloyal zealots listen
anchorman I want you to to just because
I was gonna say this this was gonna be
my closing argument it was going to be
for all you frauds all you frauds that
when it was good that's you need some
toilets in the chat when you was telling
people how you stopped you know use an
Xbox and you switched over to different
systems stated I'm not gonna say that
came because I I firmly believe that if
people can be awakened and have an
Enlightenment to let you know what
having multiple systems is a good thing
being a part of a larger game community
is a good thing I firmly believe that
people can come to that realization I
don't want these people who completely
flipped as oxx is great
PlayStation sucks then switch to
Playstations amazing xbox sux I don't
want you coming back the flip my thing
is that's so astonishing is that they
flipped at the end of the generation I
gotta get this shot with wrap two hours
of chat PC master-race salute laws but
rant I gotta get Rick ran is the voice I
want some
obviously Xbox nation is very excited
you know feeling good feeling good it
was a good moment is a moment to
generation I felt needed they didn't
have but Ren I need you to put in
perspective with the Sony counter we
know Sony's penny we know they have not
yet revealed the PlayStation 5 what do
you think they can do to try to cop a
few cameras because we all know it was
everybody got blindsided including them
like what do you think that's going
through Sony right now how could they
come back uh the Sony counter-attacks
coming yes I don't know what it's gonna
be but it's definitely good like Sony
doesn't take a lot of this stuff I would
say within three months we'll see the
song I think I think sooner than that I
think you'll see them I think they're
probably incredibly not gonna say
worried but they're looking at probably
the metrics of the announcement they
probably and I'm not gonna say they
probably didn't know because maybe Jeff
Keely offered the same deal to them we
kind of make sense and then they
probably like no we'll do it at our own
show but I'm expecting Sony I'm
expecting the gloves to come off and
this is that's why I'm so happy that
Xbox did what they did instead of all
the we'll wait to this and wait to that
Phil Spencer just is like no we're gonna
surprise you you know we only show games
that are coming out super early now
here's how blade that's you know who
knows when it's coming out and here's
ever wild and all that stuff but no I'm
expecting Sony I don't know I don't know
what it's gonna be
PlayStation 5 stuff but I'm expecting
Sony to basically not stay quiet for
very long maybe maybe Jim Ryan does
another wired article really soon but
now they're yeah I I was kind of told to
expect a Sony country now here's the I
want to jump in too cuz I listen I'm
which alright I feel this tremendous
yeah I know I've been extremely hard on
Phil dominus you know I'm saying and to
me
this was the love letter to the hardcore
right a lot of people were saying pump
the brakes but there is a reason for us
to be excited there is a reason you know
the protocol was broken for the first
time like I said when we called an order
66 it was broken for the first time
because you got a reveal early we got
the name we've got the console and then
we got a demonstration of the power
right hey let's be rude at hell-blade
y'all when you saw her face and no chips
in that engine it blew me away and
that's the game I wanted you know I'm
saying from ninja tears no disrespect
did I say something on ninja fear let's
let's get it was I actually read this
today that actually this game has been
in development before Microsoft actually
bought them I mean like so that I mean
I'm not sure if it was like a full-blown
production but you know they were
thinking about it already and so that
tells me that this game is not like a
proper proper proper Xbox series X game
mm-hmm
so I mean I I don't think we have we've
seen like all from them yet absolutely
saying that we ought to see but again
you know we'll bring up I think you're
right clove real pointed this out
actually on Twitter I think a couple
days ago if you look at the bottom right
hand corner of all their trailers right
though they shut off leading edge you
see three circles yeah so there's three
different projects okay so again it is
what it is in reference tab but again
just seeing that level like ran said the
graphical fidelity the mature title the
single-player everything that let's be
real Sony has done well this generation
right and now finally Microsoft does
that right so the question now I have is
like okay we get it
we know story's gonna come back do we
think Lockhart though they trying to
position Lockhart to counter the counter
so to speak let me go back to ran that's
what I want to ask you like is Lockhart
maybe their reason because let's be real
Michael avoids has that history of going
first right and then Sony has the
ability to counteract like almost like
Xbox in you know 2013 we know that um
it's what you call it Sony had the DRM
in a box we know that place
also had a camera but when Microsoft
went first that allows so needed to
remove that stuff get that stuff out
streamline them bring the price down the
single that's an event cost Microsoft
the whole generation let's be real it
was it was a snowball down hill effect
from that point on so do you think rain
with the to skew approach is that
possibly the counter to the counter
counter to the counter I think this is
Microsoft's trying to position
themselves as having both the power
crown and the price crown because and I
know I've said this on Xbox to and some
people won't agree with me and some
people will hate that I'm gonna say this
but to be fair I think PlayStation can
get away with being more expensive and
less powerful yes or a bigger brain yes
and there's there's people seem to like
that more so I've always said Xbox needs
as many feathers in their cap as they
possibly can get they need series acts
to be more powerful and they need a
cheaper option to compete with the
PlayStation people won't like me saying
that and I know and that's that's fine
but but look the price is gonna be
important price the most important thing
Xbox
yeah Xbox you know the DRM stuff wasn't
a good look but let's be honest they
lost because there's $100 more expensive
than than the pro that comes that
basically is what it is now as far as
the price going forward I've been saying
this since you know anaconda and
Lockhart will rumored in 2018
let's get it I'm ride until I die you
know like go go with it until the end
it's $2.99 Lockhart woe or 19 $4.99
series X oh I think that is what the
price is you are looking at for the next
gen consoles I've been thinking just
play stick that Lockhart's $2.99 that's
crazy
and then I've been thinking the
PlayStation 5 for a long time was gonna
sit right in that Goldilocks zone at 400
Wow but if that's sis so before all the
spec leaks came out I was told by people
who know it still basically and I had a
couple PC guys come at me but you know
Mads might be able to back me up here
whatever I was told that series X was
basically on par or close to a 20 atti
and that playstation 5 was basically a
20 80 right so if that's the case then I
would not be surprised if both the
playstation 5 and series X are 500 and
then Lockhart will be 299 and then that
will make Lockhart's extremely extremely
important for next generation because
that is the price point that you don't
normally don't see at a launch of a
next-gen sure like all of us here we're
gonna get we're gonna get the premium
stuff you don't get the premium system
crash alert console that launch was the
Xbox 360 arcade no I mean in the switch
was 300 but I mean that's not really a
console that ran like I do have a quick
question for you in terms of marketing
do you think they'll heavily market both
consoles equally you think they'll
market lockhardt more a believe that the
la carte will be available around what
to do I mean it's possible to la carte
won't be available at launch I know it
will be I mean it's called series extra
reason because it implies there's more
series coming so so I for anybody out
there or anybody in chat saying that la
carte doesn't exist you're wrong it does
it's always existed so wait for that to
come out and III think it's important
for Microsoft to have that option out
there 5 another console for I know
people were like whoa and I just saw a
Forbes article that just I think
somebody tweeze like people pay a
thousand dollars for phones why is it
that people can't spend 600 hours for
console it's like phones are necessity
to everyday living people pay the money
for the phones because it's something
that you use in your everyday life it's
basically an extension of you consoles
are still seen as Kitty to a certain
extent like gaming in general so and
historically
really expensive systems have done
terrible a $600 playstation3 almost sunk
PlayStation the most successful like
video game brand was almost destroyed
because they priced it too high and
fillos already said like we are not
gonna be out on power or price which
leads me to believe they're not gonna
launch at 600 so I'm sticking with $2.99
for Lockhart and I'm sticking with $4.99
for anaconda or for Series Lex now
that's what it is I don't know what
anybody else I'm glad you brought up the
phones because especially Xbox well
access is gonna be I think more Oh
laughs definitely definitely a man
playing out yeah I actually agree with
Ron for two reasons right I mean first
of all imagine imagine Lockhart at 400
play 625 at 500 right and you know
severe sex at you know 600 okay so now
you've got on a market like two consoles
like Lockhart and PlayStation 5 that
will probably have a similar cpu similar
storage all there you know nice shiny
technology and stuff but all cards would
be three times less powerful than
PlayStation 5 and cost only a hundred
dogs actually exactly smarty knows
exactly the way I'm thinking - it would
be dead on arrival
I mean fro at least from where I sit
right I mean maybe we know things but
but if you're looking at console that is
like Lockhart 300 and PlayStation 5 500
well $200 is a is a pretty nice you know
different price all right so I think so
if Microsoft will be able to do like
make Lockhart you know at five at $300 I
can I can assure that they will be able
to produce like or or sell anaconda at
500
and another another thing from like call
a cost perspective right because people
think about like twelve teraflops and
people say oh that's a lot of power
that's our TX 2080 t I gotta kind of
level of performance because it is right
because twelve twelve twelve
rDNA 2.0 teraflops that's a lot of power
right I mean that's that's really our TX
r TX 20 80 TI level a level like for
clothes level of performance right but
the thing is like like I said they the
cost
I mean our TX 20 ATT is is is being
produced a completely different
manufacturing process and that kind of
stuff right right so and like I said
like today in on a show the cost of
cheap is dictated not by the performance
or features per se but the size size of
the actual cheap mmm seven and me to
talk let's go yeah and basically like
other people think and even digit found
rip recently said how they thought that
that next next consoles you know Xbox
one I mean I might keep mixing series X
name city sex they thought that that is
going to be around 10 teraflops so did i
right but you know like um Artie um 5700
XT which everyone keeps basically
comparing these next-gen consoles to
it's very small chip that's like that's
like 250 square millimeters chip right
right Xbox one and Xbox one X chips
so both OG xbox and I mean an Xbox one
and Xbox one X chips are 360 square
millimeters right so if you if if you're
going to add additional like 20% compute
units on to that so you end up in with
like 300 right square millimeters then
to triplets right eighth course is that
we're talking about size of like around
75 square millimeters so even on a
current 700 meters plus note I mean
small
no we took in about 380 square
millimeters chip which is literally
pretty close to what Xbox one acts or
offers right now so as a result do you
know do you really think that they that
kind of chip is going to be that much
more to mass-produce No and another
thing last thing is that we're talking
about seven nanometers process but if
they're going to use our DNA 2.0 which
probably going to be produced on seven
nanometers plus EUV process right which
is going to be even cheaper to produce
because it's more simpler than that kind
stuff right and it will be able to pack
more stuff on onto it right because
because of their higher density of
transistors right you may actually end
up even with a smaller chip than that
which will make this expensive so as a
result so the last point I want to greet
plus rate so the only really expensive
thing in that box is going to be envy a
need and the nvme is not cheap so that's
my only concern but in terms of like
chips and everything it's not going to
be optically mods I do have a question
for you because I you know I'm not the
biggest I know nothing about doing
anything related to this because they
went with a bigger build like you know
that more room they want to really
shrink any kind of hardware does that
make it a little cheaper for them to
manufacture these consoles too or is it
about the same anyway probably yes
because like if you're going to stick a
big fan on top of their cool you know
you probably don't need a sophisticated
cooling system because yeah I mean how
this is still going to be there because
Hovis is actually a way of saving of
saving electricity which obviously
allows for like right you know very
cooling anyway right but you know if you
stick a huge fan on top of it I mean
it's going to you know it's it's you
don't need to use as sophisticated
coming system as you would have to use
in a smaller box right so obviously that
not they may actually save some money on
it
yeah let's take it before you guys do
that so we've got you back if you're not
gonna keep that same energy oh my god
if I if I play on PC ones for a while am
I allowed to stun confuse people about
the series we got a $5 super chat from
braat braat forte ice i am still in the
xbox ecosystem never left just the box
filled did that and it was awesome he
did we need some fraud alert system who
did that for you in the chat so we got a
$2 super track from California kid those
three dots are the loading screen it's
that fast I assume he's talking I don't
know what he's talking about 3.7 engine
theories let's go team
all right so we got a $2.00 super chair
from easy shock Lockhart will have the
biggest-selling poor SSD hmm that's
these huge did you care for tell you
what they dress up there all right so so
in Bratz still there and didn't fall
asleep on the couch somewhere no let me
rap to you for a second bro oh you I was
the one that told you about that PC a
year ago Nate took you this long to come
join me in the great economy toe over at
60 frames I'm over here too but guess
what
I didn't really I didn't give and put my
xbox 1x in the Kitty room don't let my
kids play with it I still log into my
xbox every day it's like death D on my
xbox every day and do all those great
and did it happily but you on the other
hand completely abandon us master race
and you felt like you've been there for
what you saying game Forte is witty
soprano let's in that shower let's go
get that system come on YouTube he won't
be he gonna unbox his own because he
want to do the one you know with the you
know the key thing he's gonna use to
take it away if all this I'm a content
creator I have to cover it below 40 I
did that price where you take that said
Oh spot on shout the brat I said how's
that spider-man Forte so I'll be price
my baby we gotta get price it'll get a
blue ball man so a lot of compelling
things we're talking I am I am King Lord
of that $600 price tag okay I just
that's what I just believe is gonna come
in at but the one thing I will acquiesce
on that is Microsoft is they have shown
the duplicity willing each to underprice
stuff I mean affected they keep giving
us services like game pass em
consistently for the price that they're
doing it lets us know that the money
isn't the issue so I can see this system
coming at 500 if they're willing to lose
a little money on the on the back end on
the front end to get more people in on
the back end right but that's the only
way I see it hitting that price point
but I just see when I look at my PC hat
off because being a PC gamer it's kind
of hard to equate what PC is vs consoles
and how that architecture comes together
in the price point that they can that
you're doing that because they are mass
producing these on a very very large
scale and that does bring costs down I
just feel like for me the stuff that
they're talking about this system doing
with envy Emmys and
and we're talking about nabhi sucking
Jen we're talking about racing we're
talking about Rachel we're talking all
that stuff and we're talking about
graphics cards that bring games to their
knees on PC mm-hm I'm just saying it's
$600 is just that it feels like that is
the ceiling it should be air but out but
trust me I would love a $500 system oh
god don't let this man like you use
talking about willing to pay that's a
completely different discussion right
there's what you're willing to pay what
it's gonna be
I'm willing to pay $800 because I feel
like if that system is worth it I feel
like I'm gonna get the benefits of that
I want to have a PC like experience on
my console without all the PC problems
that I have eight hundred dollar price
tag I'll buy it
guess what if they do it at 500 even
better it'll make it easier for me to go
out and buy a Playstation five on launch
by or watch games they got on launch get
game pants or whatever else I need I
already have that for the next two or
three years because of mr. tell them
about what these on PC you guys I mean
there's no but I think that's the
biggest thing I think it just really
comes down to if Microsoft continues
what they're doing now because this is
basically the floor now this is this is
the minimum expectations I have from
Microsoft when it comes to the way that
they're communicating what they're
talking about their marketing the way
that they're bringing out these these
overall experiences and how they're
gonna talk about them I want to see more
of this going forward great I'm a
hundred percent back in I will be there
day one to pick up this system and it's
all in Sony's court and basically I
think Sony is gonna surprise it's just
like everybody else
now the cutout of the counter it could
be that Lockhart it could be the price
point it could be all those things in
general but I just think Microsoft right
now is 66% of the way to the win that
33% or 34% more is the content that they
bring to the platform if they can
the Platt department if they can knock
that part out they win power they win
price they win games they win the
generation even if they don't win the
generation when it comes to total sales
because they're not available in all
countries we all know it just it's just
perception at that point if Xbox is on
everybody's mind in a positive manner
and not like this negative conversation
we had through this whole generation
when he came to Xbox Microsoft wins they
don't have to win in sales to win in our
minds I need your price point where I'm
with Forte I've been leaning towards
$600 especially after seeing it I feel
like if they're gonna do a console like
the to race they can get away with like
how can I say this I feel like the
market conditions for gaming what people
with consumers are willing to spend on
high-end electronics and smart devices
has gone up you know it's not like 2600
looks for a console in 2006 was asinine
but 600 hours for a console in 2020
probably not that bad honestly so when
you think about what think about what
things costed us back in 2006 rent
wasn't is high in 2006 like you know I
mean like like all sorts of things that
we will buy it like when you walk into a
store but man I can't I can't like you
know push $600 given the stuff that I
got to pay for outside of like gaming so
that's why it wears nowadays rent is
much higher the capacity for things that
were buying nowadays is higher iPads
tablets phones gasses Alexis back to
Alexis take gas right everything is is
higher so it's like it'll be the
reaction wouldn't be that crazy
especially when you have multiple
devices now if it's five dollars fine
but my ceiling on a console for me
personally is $600 I I would be fine
buying it on the series X for $600
because I'm only going to be spending
plus taxes well you say $25 in taxes and
then $10 for game pass I'm good
and where you got la carte if you have
sex that's weird
all right so Lockhart Randy I think
$2.99 would be lovely but I say it would
be through 99 cause I firmly believe
that the PlayStation 5 will be $4.99
well here's the thing so here's the
thing this is why I find the $5.99 for
first four series X and the 399 for
lac-arts I don't see crap I don't I
don't thread that because who's to say
Sony doesn't just come in with PS 5 at
399 the entire generation for Microsoft
like that would be you imagine if Sony
comes in with a system almost as
powerful series X the price it's the
same as the cheap Lockhart as I'm saying
like I look at that I'm like nah man
like they need to make sure that
Lockhart is way cheaper than any the
$200 offered that the price difference
needs to represent you know how much
better the other system is right but
when we start pricing and higher so if
you're pricing Lockhart at 400 you don't
really know what your competition do is
like you have a clue but maybe they're
willing to lose money on it and then
they announce you imagine Microsoft at
e3 be like we got Series exit
you know $5.99 and maybe they sell it
really good and it looks amazing
okay yeah I'll pay $600 for that oh we
got la carte at 399 and then the next
day because Sony will go after and
they're just as good as series X and
it's 399 which is the same as the the
Bunco Xbox anything was said about the
la carte that's what I agree with ran at
that point date date that's the main
reason why don't think the la carte even
came up I don't think the la cartes
gonna come up at e3 until I actually
know what Sony's gonna do I subscribed
down to that $2.99 for that lock card
because it has to be as price disparity
between the eggs is over a TS
I don't end of the day if even if it
comes in a 299 and
$4.99 or $5.99
I I think like I said yet last night I
think Microsoft's about to take a loss
on both call they're either gonna take a
loss on the on the X nothing that's
right oh well they might they might what
they don't really have to if they if
they meet price with the X if the X ends
up being the same prices of five that
means they're gonna eat the price there
because I think it's gonna be a more
powerful system then they're just gonna
price the S the S at a way lower price
like $200 cheaper does show the price
what I think if they if they priced it
to a journalist cheaper I think they're
taking a loss there too they might be
more willing to take a hit on both but
especially the Lockhart because if the
rumors are true and it doesn't have a
disk drive right to cut a cost that
means you know is a company that anybody
who is buying software for your system
is doing digitally I mean they're buying
from your store so you're getting a
better percentage right and then more
than likely they're also gonna be
subscribing to gain pass right yeah
right so they might be really willing to
get that system as cheap as possible so
they can you know because they know that
customer is going to be locked into the
ecosystem with digital games and
subscriptions you know cuz of question I
have for you is don't you think Randy
would be even in Bouldin to really be
aggressive with the lockhardt price
especially recently with the success of
the sad / Adi UK right well yeah but see
that the set could always have done well
it was just was price a great 150 bucks
nobody wants it for that price but you
start talking about 150 no problem so
what to me what that proved to me for
the fact that they outsold the switch in
the PlayStation in UK with a system that
let's be eyes especially in the UK I
thought my opinion was outdoor casuals
would never flock to a diskless system
but it goes to show you right if the
price point is low enough and right
people will go out there so I'm actually
with you on that ran the question I have
for you gonna bring it back is back to
Lockhart again and Forte's got me
thinking about something with III again
III is the gamesmanship right yeah
Sunday is Microsoft's day most
likely if Sony's gonna be there this
year Monday might be their day right so
is there a scenario where you think that
Lockhart's price could not be revealed
right no I think so you can have to show
both skills at eat on that Sunday or no
I don't think that I personally informed
before I think if anything they're gonna
do it after e3
I think Locker yeah I think III is gonna
be all about the X I think they're gonna
show all the bases they don't want to
have mixed messaging on that stage so
he's gonna be they're gonna be one
presentation around that X integral say
these are the gangsters coming to our
next-gen system our next-gen high-end
system now let me go talk about the
other system until they know what the
floor is for PlayStation I mean they
have to there's gonna be a rollout they
happen it's not they're not gonna hide
Lockhart for that long when the series X
release date and pricing is available we
will find about series s pricing
available I don't think they're gonna
hold on just a wait until but here's
here's the question how do they do it at
e3 or do they do it at an event whatever
event that they will reveal the price
and release date that's when we're gonna
do it so whether that be major G at a
question I got a question for Ren rent
and your personal opinion do you think
that they would wait till III to reveal
everything else I think they do their
own event do you think they handle
Lockhart there with the wheels of both
SKUs just guess I've thought I've always
thought like next year would have a
reveal event for PlayStation mm-hmm
February and then Microsoft would reveal
their system in like March or something
like that I'm doing it at the VGA s so
sure they're gonna have a reveal event
cuz because they don't necessarily they
revealed the console like you know the
name but to be fair they were right I
think they reveal price beforehand why
because they are if they already know
that Xbox is coming with two SKUs right
so automatically you already sandwiched
in there right it what does it matter to
break the price to T not right now price
when you when you reveal the system I
said
matter to a Blair yeah to be fair play
playstation like they only have one
console reveal like I feel like what
would make sense is they wait for the
PlayStation console reveal and then they
do a lock our console reveal from a lot
of beat up guys the White Walkers listen
listen listen red is right
alright and and the more sit down and I
think about is this is a classic pincer
attack deaf singer you understand what
pincer is cuz we do it and pop G all the
time
it's a classic pincer attack you get the
enemy in the middle and you squeeze them
from both ends now you might not have
full firepower at one side but you do
have enough of a distraction on one end
that the full firepower was coming from
another angle and then once you get the
headshot boom you take them out fats so
you have the Lockhart that [ __ ] your
little trump right that's your little
ace in the hole this is what you're
holding right here just in case dudes
act out of pocket so if they happy
holidays everyone great topics in
conversation do we think a diskless
digital only Xbox appeal to the mass
market console is split between physical
and digital purchases more recently we
have seen an increase in physical sales
okay we got a call because this is
forties all right um so when we use in
the lock card that's the ace in the hole
right this is this is the ignition in
the room is the elephant sitting in the
corner waiting for you to act up and set
price so when you said price I don't
think Microsoft has to set price until
probably in the middle of the
week of III we know they can show games
they have the fan fest event going on
they're gonna show games they're gonna
show the system on deck they will wait
for Sony to jump out the window first
once they jump out the window first and
I believe Sony's gonna come in at 400
399 or 400 maybe that might be a sweet
spot but then you got to look at the
stocks to see if they're able to swallow
that loss because it will be a loss on
each systems if you're saying that this
system is only probably 20 to 30 percent
more powerful than the PlayStation 5
which I don't think that will cut it
okay I don't think that will cut it it
must be a little bit more higher
probably 40% more powerful than the
PlayStation I think Microsoft meets them
at price mm all right so I think the
price of the PlayStation has to be $4.99
for them to turn a profit right and like
like Rand said they have a bigger brand
and they can sell at a higher price
point they can get a more a bigger chunk
of their money back
Microsoft will have to sell it a loss
and it will have to meet them at price
point you're not gonna beat them at
price but to undercut to get the guys
that are coming in with the cheap
pockets right cheap pocket-sized no no
listen the reason why the PlayStation
sold the last generation even even the
fact that it was more powerful it was
cheaper you know a hundred dollars is a
lot somebody said that they're gonna go
inside the store they're gonna buy X a
series X and they're going to get game
Pass
you see they walk away with all the
launch titles right there right with the
system and extra games when you going to
buy a Playstation you have to buy a
Playstation
you have to buy extra games you have to
buy a controller so your overall
purchase is going to turn into something
astronomical when the overall purchase
for Microsoft is going to be at a
different rate so I believe the defense
attack will definitely be in I do not
believe that they're going to announce
Lockhart's price point but I do believe
everything that Rand is saying is
spot-on all right
what answer that I gotta get Forte to
answer brap with the digital physical
then randon attic and then we moving on
yeah when it comes to that I think the
biggest thing to realize is that the ex
I mean that the ex but the sad addition
the audit aversion yes it will Ranas
right it would always done well the
price point is what basically murdered
that system when it first came out
because I can't give exact numbers but
we had a substantial amount of those
systems at the beginning of this month
and no store in my region has any of
them so if it wasn't for the fact that
the PlayStation 5 was with three games
was selling for $1.99
the ps4 sorry if it wasn't for that I
think Xbox could easily probably won
this ginger that's his year but this
muffin MPD if they actually if that
wasn't a deal with the PlayStation so I
think the system could definitely work
people do not mind buying their digital
games because they already do it we had
quite a few of those digital systems
more than I thought we were going to
carry right and we sold out of them
literally the week that they launched at
that 150 price point Wow he was
everywhere yeah shout to Jonathan B with
the files of a chat did no no no we got
one before him oh yes soundly with two
dots which I thanks Kay Xbox series X
has a disk drive that was shocking what
that doesn't really shocked me because
they want that cranium 4k blu-ray in
there because they want to be able to
really sell that absolutely radiant blue
no soft want to get Jonathan B that's a
Jonathan B with a $5 super chat did
everyone get hit with the Scarecrow's
fear toxin while I was sleeping here why
are people so sick by the series x
hashtag son was teeth don't give me
nightmares mode addicts off you got a
job now well at the end of the day when
it comes to this ow I'm gonna keep this
short sweet yeah I think I used to think
that the console would be $5.99 and the
Lockhart be 399 but I ran won me over a
little bit man
I think I think the antic on is gonna be
$4.99 in the lock call I still think the
law cards going to be 399 I said that's
the worst thing they could like that was
gonna bring up like they would not do
their normal pricing structure of X 499
la carte 399 why not round please
because because drop a hundred and
completely destroy the whole play the
thing is if the Lockhart is is 399 and
it's considerably weaker than the PS 5
and it comes in the 399 you had a
problem well it's like cuz you already
tried you did that with the 360 you had
two SKUs and it was a hundred dollar
difference but the only difference was
the twenty gig hard drive even the ps3
did that as well that's two excuse um
and even though there was a 499
PlayStation what did what did people
always say it's $5.99 right right
cuz it doesn't matter the hundred
hundred dollars isn't really that much
off for a lot of people especially that
high when you're talking about five
hundred to four hundred right so to me
if you're trying to demonstrate how much
more powerful series X is then Lockhart
has to be priced accordingly and a
hundred dollar difference
isn't that right now two hundred dollar
difference though if you start looking
at that man it's not willing to take
that kind of loss like I think it's
personal like you said especially if
there's no disk drive and I think one of
the biggest factors that they have this
go coming in this gym that they didn't
have last year is I think game pass is
gonna come full effect with next-gen I
think I think meeting money hand over
fist with game pass so they worry less
about they don't come here I was I was
in a reset era thread at you know where
they were asking people what do you
think about the ex what the series X and
so many people in the dre were like I'm
gonna have gamepad from PC I'm good it
look but I don't need it mmm-hmm and I
think field is fine with that this is
this is this is the part where you are
the genius behind all the moves before
was looking haphazard it wasn't looking
put together the puzzle is forming now
so no matter where you go you gonna be
in that game past ecosystem when you're
walking down the street and you're
having your phony doing X cloud you're
in an ecosystem where you're playing on
your X when you're playing on your s
when you're playing on your series X
when you're playing on your series s
you're in this ecosystem when you're on
your PC breath you are on the ecosystem
and I think I remember is you know with
game pass guaranteed you getting at
least a month to three months of game
pass in me an ox right so now you're
talking about you getting your system
with launch titles in the box
not to mention craziness in the and what
I want to point out it's like at the
beginning of the jet obviously you are
the package of compatible games but
they'll go into a lot of people with
that cave especially if they go from ps4
to Xbox where they don't have a whole
lot of games they won't have any games
but that game past chances are because
how you know appealing that game past
look so there's a good chance that
they'll pick up like the 2k and they'll
just keep the game pass but you think
about it
you get that game press and you gonna be
playing listen listen the millions rule
be right put that millions in that check
the millions is playing as these baby oh
I hope that's not a price way but I mean
I've been six hundred because I just
thought but it to be honest like hearing
all these different opinions today like
if you go six and Sony's willing to take
that L and they give you something
that's powerful but not super less
powerful at one hundred dollar price
point you're in trouble and notice that
at the VGA there to talk about price for
a reason right yeah so I agree I think
price of year early people understand we
out with what
what I'm saying is usually they like let
us see one or not the other like they
let us see what that not only what it
looked like what it was called like way
before and they normally do that right
no it's interesting man I mean finish up
self it's five I think it's five and I
do think Lockhart is three you guys make
compelling points I think I have one
more thing oh we do Rango go for it
also like when we're talking about
taking a loss or whatever you got also
keep in mind that the systems aren't
just the systems right they they serve
another purpose they're gonna put
lockhart into the cloud yes correct
cloud yeah so it's like Microsoft wants
to sell it for $2.99 or whatever and
take a loss and be like well maybe they
will but then you also got to realize
that they're gonna be put in Lockhart
into the cloud so people can play those
games everywhere so it's it's not like
it just it serves more than one function
is basically what I'm getting across um
and I don't think they'll actually put
series acts into the cloud until much
later they'll do Lockhart first yes for
like the 1440p 60 frame stuff and stuff
like and stuff like that but yeah that's
that's B we haven't mentioned it because
nobody's really thinking X cloud right
but when you're when you're Microsoft if
you're thinking about what you're going
to use these systems for and all the
hard money like you know when you're
going to Satya and you're going to AMI
hood and you're asking for money and
they're gonna be like okay what's your
plan mm-hmm you know you got to have all
this stuff basically you know ready to
go so it's like yeah they're also gonna
put it into the cloud which helps
mitigate some of the price because they
hope you know actually they hope game
streaming is gonna be big eventually
down the road and they want to dominate
that's the last thing on the thing is
very just like run around I she said
that is going to be used in the cloud
but you need to remember that Phil did
say that it's going to be used for
streaming which we know about already
right but also I remember him couple of
months ago saying that these blades
these next-generation blades going to be
used only for productive purposes so
meaning that if you are a company that
are dealing with some AI calculations is
that you go to Microsoft they will be
using no locker or anaconda blades to
actually make money off of these
companies and they are paying a lot of
money
mmm so they can yes so thank you follow
a little bit of loss on these blades I
think no shouted Mohammad Diallo with
the 30 fighter I don't know what see
let's see our country code
I gotta learn it Microsoft ain't playing
this time Sony goes 400 Microsoft calls
400 with series ex-gay pass will take
care of the rest
look this is HS but it's really exciting
um I can't fret man I think initially
coming in I was on a little higher price
point than all you got no South African
Rand South Africa all salute salute our
brothers for South Africa mean that's
what's up man um yeah like I think I
came in a little high but listening nut
mods when he talks you know from a
manufacturing and a production
standpoint how things can be much
cheaper things can be mitigated in that
respect oh my god shut off the double
bulb in the building 20 dollars support
is a support for mr. and mrs. fools dick
happy holidays brother thank you so much
brother let his brother back good guy
and um you know when you hear that for
the manufacturer standpoint did you hear
ran and ran makes compelling arguments
which is look you know they can't afford
obviously to lose the power it does he
changed my opinion that's yeah you know
and you know coming in making this thing
an attractive option would PlayStation
there you know I was of the mindset
initially that when the Xbox were next
drop that day were embolden with the
five hundred dollar price point because
they I'll be honest Rand I think you
know I we set it around the X about the
project Scorpio reveals like teams they
go 500 that's a mistake it kind of
proved me wrong because it was like they
sold so well at that price when people
were willing to pay for the premium
product at that time however you know
stakes are different you know I mean
Sony is coming they have to have a
compelling attack and this is where I
kind of side with King with king of his
his famous pincer attack you know they
they shouted a pizza which
you know you kind of got to get it from
both sides you know I'm saying you gotta
have to let them know okay if we have
our bigger box here you know I'm saying
the price has to be kind of equal level
you know and not that much more
expensive also the Lockhart has to
undercut them so that's where I'm at
look if we could get 300 and 500 for two
skills that's super impressive you know
I hope so I'll be there and to be honest
that that sounds like unrealistic like
thinking about it but if it happens it's
like it's my only question I sent back
to random odds I see what y'all going
with with with Series X and anaconda I
just struggle with the 304 Locker
only because you know we know series
I'll be serious I mean the series s most
likely Lockhart is in that space about a
little bit slightly above that space of
where the Xbox one X is right so if that
is the case there's 300 like you guys
say think it maybe you know you just
think the Xbox one X is completely
phased out yes yeah yeah yeah why would
they hit why would they have it like
it's but they're mean buta much apple
juice I done when I've said that on
Twitter people would be like oh they are
they really gonna discontinue the X
after only three years and like what did
discontinued the OG xbox one after three
years mmm-hmm like the Lockhart like
people get people get confused when
Lockhart when they say Lockhart is for
teraflops because they look at the X and
c6 and manse can tell me with them right
Lockhart's for teraflop rDNA X the X is
six teraflop Polaris which is GCN the
the the Lockhart GPU is basically more
efficient than the X's and the power
level is basically the same but then
Lockhart's also gonna have the next-gen
CPUs then - yes and of the nvme SSD yes
it's gonna probably have the same amount
of RAM but like djidi djidi dr6 so it's
like it's a much yeah right it's a much
better console in every way like it'll
run circles around the absolutely right
my measuring is over there yeah so it
doesn't make sense for Microsoft to have
that console on the market and
considering the like if you look at the
MSRP right now on the X it's still $500
it's Arab so it's like to me that just
says okay you have Series X they chose
that name for a reason you have this
cheaper one coming they're just gonna be
like stop production on the Xbox one X
we're done with that they'll still make
the the cheaper s 199 150 for the sad
because they're gonna be people that
want to you know still by the older
gentle press what I think is gonna
happen so even before I gave it to mom
even with the whole messaging mantra of
bringing all your devices they they're
making this whole inclusive kumbaya
marketing that no one's getting left
behind you can use your old device with
your new device even with that you still
say based on the length of the time the
X has been on the market the Xbox one X
that is time that they will still be
able face I'm not saying they're they're
gonna stop supporting the X I'm just
saying they're gonna stop making it and
selling it obviously they're gonna
support the X for years and years they
don't support at the 360 to like forever
yeah it depends on what they consider to
be their baseline now like what if what
if they've repackage the X as the new
baseline literally repackage it take out
I don't you good yeah I mean actually
yeah R and actually stole my yeah the
fact that they going to stop producing
the console doesn't necessarily mean
that they won't they would also start
stop supporting and I think that people
actually confuse that yeah brand maker
that's it shout out to 6:00 a.m. with
the file switcher lockout will be $2.99
or less and it's fine with Microsoft
since it's likely using chips that
didn't pass muster to run in the
anaconda their recouping money and then
saw if you want to get lured 0og Louis P
with the $10 stupid chat here's a little
for the lords and my brothers for the
holidays great crew on the show today
exciting time for gaming now
I'm just happy devil may cry one half
shut up you got a great auto come up for
the Lord's giving that day look we got
to move on but on your ran miles you
guys are definitely selling me your may
be on to something if they hit those two
price points wow wow wow that would be
tremendous so we got a please do these
two in a combo topic as we gotta get out
soon
um Lord addict I know me and you were
talking about the arm we got the undead
lab announcement and then we also got
MLB to show so I'll breeze through the
under labs right so shout out to those
dudes and undead Geoff straight look
like they just made an announcement
recently and they were talking about the
studio head and founder Jeff strange
starting a new initiative and basically
he said that you know their game
development needs a bigger base and they
talked about him being a small-time guy
you know I guess from New Orleans and
they said with the support of Xbox at
Microsoft Jeff's going to continue his
role as a studio head at undead labs
while also building opportunities to
bring in people who might otherwise
consider a career in the game industry
maybe even someone with the vision of
the next state of the Kay is out there
waiting for the right opportunity that's
all we can say right now but we will
share more information as soon as we can
so it feels like undead lamps is
expanding and shout to the good people
from the lab we've actually met with
them at PAX and great great team so good
to hear this stuff so I want to British
the ring might know what's going on you
know red like do you feel I gotta get
ready glad knows every you know say so
do you feel with this announcement you
know they are looking at other
initiative similar telecom engineer Ian
bigger game what does this mean rain I
honestly have no clue I honestly don't
know I I asked jazz the same thing last
night and he said was his exact words to
me let me let me let me check the DM DM
is between me and mr. just Gordon senior
editor right senior editor
let's go see where did ya we talked so
much in these dams like I know I mean I
think he's just trying to maybe like
find some people who maybe weren't given
the opportunities or didn't have the
opportunity to become game developers it
didn't it doesn't actually sound like
it's another like it's a new studio like
the initiative isn't a new studio or
like the other studio that playground
built to make their open-world RPG it
seems more like an initiative to kind of
help people become game developers yeah
that's what I thought that's that's
that's kind of what just it's just an
open mic for you to go spit your new
barge said he said let's see if like
they're the only Microsoft studio right
now that has like one franchise right we
don't hear about an additional project
other than state of decay from undead
lab so you you don't think that do you
think that there is possibility of
multiple projects or everything there's
all hands on deck for the next state of
the cave three or what have you I think
there are lands on deck for state of the
catering yeah I think the reason that
this was mainly done is they wanted to
be able to open up more talent and the
only way they can do that is to be in
another region no kid you also had you
know what do you did man what's your
feeling on this whole announcement I
thought they were just I thought he was
a it seemed like is still related to
undead labs and state occasions I think
it was geared towards like um I think
stay decayed development at first not
right at all right this is their second
studio because remember Lahti studios
that got purchased by Microsoft they end
up opening like either expanding whether
Baha'i are opening up us like a second
studio um and I think this is just
really having like another pretty much
location for them to be in two places at
once
being that
- k3 could be like a bigger game or
maybe having like a studio set up to
like keep like I guess live updates
going on the existing game so I tried to
like at first I was reading like oh just
do gonna still be heavy undead left and
start his own little multi plaid
independent studio so I honestly don't
know but I but after reading it seemed
like it still related to undead labs and
static ad they said they did this with
the help of Microsoft so interesting
because in the actual update that they
made they actually stated that you know
them being in that city will kind of
limits them to talent yeah where are
they located there are no Orleans I
believe I believe there no no isn't that
where the new one is this is where the
new Academy they said it wasn't going on
that's right right right so I think
that's one of the reasons you see people
like rock star have so many outlets is
to be able to absorb so much talent
around the world yeah this is crazy
[ __ ] so let me get on okay so I heard
you trippin I think it's I think it's
this is not getting as much to play as
it as it needs to they're allowing him
to continue to stay as the head of
undead labs while a creating another
studio which if it's if it's partnering
with Microsoft you can assume they're
gonna be focusing on Microsoft
development whatever that is right be
the Academy is for them to be able to
start bringing up homegrown talent right
things so I think it's forward-thinking
of Microsoft to figure out a way to
bring talent that they nurture
themselves and bring into the ecosystem
to their various you know 15 teams so I
think the fact that he's a lot they're
allowing Jeff to stay at the head of
undead is very telling that this is a
straight-up Microsoft and initiative for
strengthening all of their studios I
think Bush is real quick oh no I'm here
no I think overall is it's definitely a
really good thing I think Mike the one
thing
people always try to get Microsoft flat
force and not having developers then
actually know what a good game is is
what people keep trying to say like they
don't know their developers aren't as
good as Sony developers and the biggest
thing always people talk about is Sony
developers talk to communicate amongst
each other that's how you see when of
Kojima they had guerilla games over
there helping out with that game how the
partnership between all those Studios
work
I think this Academy is just another way
for Microsoft agreed in grown talent and
be able to get more of get more out of
their own people versus have an
outsourced and go you know be mercenary
and tape you from other developers and
stuff like that so if they do it that
way I think it's definitely a really
good option for them to do because
they're basically just saying hey this
is a place we're going to teach you to
crab and if you are already part of the
game studio this is the place you can
hone those crafts to be even better than
you are now and it's all gonna be under
underneath the Microsoft hood if that's
basically what I understand it to be
honestly Mike so hood Johnathan be with
the fire on a super chair undead labs is
gonna sign Cash Money Records to take
over the nine but do what they doing yet
yeah I mean like why not I mean if if
that means that they they'll keep
growing and you know and hiring new
developers or training you developers
because that's what I'm hearing they
want to do right I mean that's good I
mean that's good for them it that's good
for Microsoft that's good for Xbox
I guess that's even good for well the
whole industry because the more
developers and we know that you know the
quality is everything so you know I
guess that you know properly trained the
calipers will you know deliver hopefully
quality games but I was under the
impression that they actually building a
new new team just like my ground game is
actually no I mean that was my first
stretch and it's both it's both studio
and a development Academy so it's both
things yes I would imagine that like
yeah so I mean like playground games
basically just built another like even
like a built physically building I'd
it's like they ranting they built their
building a building for the new studio
so I was like under the impression
that's not the same thing with with
undead labs than they are actually going
to have another dedicated team to work
on other projects and hiring and
teaching other developers how to code
whatever right so I mean that was my
initial impression but like but I didn't
really look properly into that right I
would love another to see some people
actually run with 18 Studios already
because they are counting like actually
teams not the extra Studios Fred of King
where we were rocket we broke bread with
the Lords of undead I think that um
nothing but great things for the
studio's warranted the level of passion
that they showed even before being
acquired by Microsoft and a lot of level
of dedication that they have today base
is incredible um a lot of times people
try to say that Microsoft doesn't allow
the studios to do the things that they
need to do to be great alright I
purchased them and they say that
Microsoft is a stifling entity upon
these developers and you know they want
to point to a Bungie as Bungie needed to
get away so now you see them cultivating
their development teams and they
allowing their development teams to
branch off in different ways to show
that they have the support of the parent
company and the gaming division as a
whole so in order to say okay Jeff you
still at the head of this de Labs but I
understand that you wanted to start like
an internship type of thing bring people
in and to see how talented today they
are and we can have them grow here with
us and they could be put into the
company through this way I believe
that's genius because you allow in the
minute who tells you that I can
multitask
I can bring in more talent and we do
need more talent in this area
and I would like to have somebody with
fresh new ideas opposed to taking a
retread from someplace else coming in
with their old ideas new stuff we're
going to a new age
so you need new talent and I think it's
nothing but great things and of course
it will take this studio that is this
bold this brash and that's out there to
do it
first I mean and I'm maybe there's more
Studios that are about to do it but you
know the fact that they're doing the
first is fantastic it wasn't he said
that just ray asked you what's a goon to
a goblin
but is it wasn't they one of the first
that was purchased by - over the first
day they were right but we had them one
right when they won NPD and after the
announcement so it was real good shot -
those guys yepez you know I'm saying and
the whole crew Brandt and fogey know
guys that were there and stuff like that
was just a great team great energy so
it's exciting to see what they have
going on you know we gonna move on last
topic Lord King
ya know it's uh yeah MLB the show what
of the most highly anticipated baseball
games it seems to be going multi plant
so Saudis best-selling baseball
franchise it's no longer exclusive so
the world ending confirmed the Major
League Baseball confirm tension of its
licensing deal with Sony and the
statement confirmed the MLB franchise
will move to new platform for the first
time ever
MLB the show 20 is already scheduled for
a march 2020 release on PlayStation 4
but this series could make the jump to
Xbox and switch as early as 2021 so the
internet was a bit of a tizzy with this
one a lot of people were upset you know
for nation as far as you know this stuff
so I mean King you can set this off you
know I know this was your topic
part of 18 I walk around the table with
the baseball bat in his hands from after
Untouchables right we are part of a team
and in this team you
all must play ball and I will never
forget car going up to Phil and one of
his greatest questions is you know but
what about baseball dope yeah I just say
that and he said you know the licensing
this stuff is complicated this is our
meticulousness individual when you send
over white paper to a company MLB and
you say listen we have X amount of
systems so we have this amount of system
sold we're generating this type of
revenue and this is what game pass is
doing here and we'll be fantastic to
have your game in this ecosystem so you
can generate this amount of money this
is the money that you're missing out
playing ball with the one boos don't
think for one second that that forum did
not go out Batman did not tell him that
we can do this for you don't think one
second that all of a sudden your
girlfriend is having such a good time
with fear she tells you I need a Birkin
bag he looked right out to assess I need
a Birkin bag why you need a Birkin back
and somebody told me that Birkin bags of
fun and I need it Oh play ball with this
Birkin bag yes what's gonna happen
somebody else gonna buy that Birkin bag
for now Microsoft has got that Burke
your bag ready to go and Noah said it's
only had no choice but to capitulate and
and it's I love the fact that the new
guy in charge didn't tell her go ahead
and walk we know why where she was a
little walk right across the street to
get that Birkin bag from Microsoft so we
know how it's gonna go now guys we know
now and I could not wait to get on here
to tell you guys that Microsoft has got
that catcher's mitt and inside they
catch me we thought it inside the Birkin
bag because the money is already sent
we're playing baseball over here cover
yourself
okay he's already shot the JD game of
father Sanchez so we get triple a state
of the k-3 a second triple a level in
the Xbox cool to bring
Deb's in the Xbox wave Xbox is on fire
hashtag long game and Sony's in trouble
and then Victor Alice teen you want to
get that soft Celtic Dallas thing with
the $5 super chat David Jaffe actually
said he would buy a series X / PS 5 just
for game pass you know how far we go Wow
one bad mother-- $10 sewage a Happy
Holidays ILP we finally seen the results
of Phil's promotion two years ago some
couldn't see it but that don't matter
community over plastic no special energy
should be needed to reach any man is
really in a frenzy over this you know
you know me and you are MLB to show
hardcore fans I mean you would buy the
PlayStation specifically for that as
well as diversion but I saw you know you
I'm just I'm happy all the way around
I'm be honest I shout out to everybody
who has not ever had the opportunity to
play the show for whatever reason you
know I if it's some hatred for Sony I'm
not as happy for you but whatever what
honestly this is a great this is great
for for baseball across the board is
great for Sony Sony's gonna have a lot
of money in their pockets a shot with
this it's a new development studio oh ya
know the funny thing is I you know we
still don't know details of certain
things I don't know if Sony's gonna
outsource the the ports hey or do it
themselves um hey so there's still some
details they have not been clarified
handle it you gonna put it on you but to
be honest MLB - oh they have they
they've elevated this franchise year in
and year out again they have nine months
to make a new game every single year
and although I you know I fell off a
little bit just because I feel like I
haven't had enough time to play they see
all the new stuff so it just feels like
the same old game over and over again
it's it's absolutely not
do you remember when we what was it it
was at e3 or was it packs it was it
packs I was like oh I'm getting it this
year yeah we remember at that time I'm
sitting there with lord carbide so we
going over videos we're doing a video
mm-hmm and I'm training him on some
other stuff but we're looking at the
show and I'm like you did you check it
out and I say hey wouldn't it be great
if it's on Xbox you said not a date so
um I think it's a great move all across
the board the fact that it is a sports
franchise and pretty much the only
sports franchise that is locked to one
system it's kind of weird I know MLB we
saw that and they said look yeah went to
Sony they said this is the deal we love
the game we'd love you to keep making it
the game these are the stipulations you
say no if you say no we're gonna open it
up to everybody I don't I don't know
that he is is in the conversation I know
we're in the conversation question who
do you think they would have given if at
Sony did not decline who you think will
publisher you think they would have
given it to the oh you know okay the way
worked out now right is that they're
only first parties could make it right
EA has never made they've never come out
and said that hey they would love to do
it I would love to get em oh-- he since
MVP raised water been trying to get back
in the game remember
so if EA was kind of knocking at the
door saying what was going on and then
you think about it if they would have
Sony were to walk away from it
completely then they have to figure out
what happens it's only San Diego like
what do you do LP paddle read kid
Cognito etc you're gonna have to let all
those Saudi contracts are there people
back
don't hurt this off get the Victor Alice
dear isn't it possible so when he could
do the two release - yeah I thought I
thought about that and I said Wow you
know this is a high possibility because
a lot of people keep saying oh you know
they're fearful that Sonny's gonna do
this thing because they don't understand
you know how Sonny can be petty because
they took an hour for that show and he
moved the camera and the DRM out the box
and lowered the price or they had the
price without the UM the big camera side
so everything is possible do you think
they're gonna do it hmm I don't think so
but I truly honestly believe that
everything is possible and we all are in
for a great ride coming up 0og find out
so protect the kind of thing happening
more should have been expected Gaming is
rapidly breaking down barriers that have
been around for a long time that's good
okay so it's so hard I just want to
point a see you later breath I want to
say before Brad please write songs but
it's the water me and Brett might argue
we might fight but Brett still the fam
we saw what everyone and they don't you
worry you go get a bang fantastic I
think the boot got put to the neck and
they and Sony is when he said you know
what what are we gonna do is already San
Diego if we just walk away right they
can be baseball for 20 years so honestly
I'm glad they decided to continue making
the game and to make more money and it's
a great thing so I don't have a choice
something I mean listen I don't want
anybody on this panel to really believe
that Sony had a choice what was the
choice it was either get on a lay down
and they choose to get down they didn't
want to lay in the dirt off of this so
they're already losing their franchises
to PC there's a Rick listen the stigma
is stinking up the phone I want to know
at what point
in time are y'all gonna start ringing
that Bell because everybody keeps you
know Sony might be coming back is Sony's
doing they've been taking loss after
loss after loss at what point in time
are you gonna start calling a spade a
spade because it had all this stuff
happened America saw you guys are be
hell
Jim Ryan's doing a little games my man
over there Jim Pam boys are taking the L
good brother brother Kratos Oh this
announcement went down and King me you
got a tweet for the creators he was like
here baby
Jim ride is messing it up he was like
these men are a lot of stuff go loose
like right now I gotta bring this to
king of rent right now because of this
move I've seen a lot of the Sony
faithful very upset and and not liking
you know exclusives either going to PC
and especially MLB which was soon
ominous with Sony like like it I got
aspirin get ready gets it some other way
like what is your feeling when you see
Sony faithful this upset by this move
well when I see when I see those those
fanboys lose their minds I love it I
mean I'm in them bushes with my pocket I
think of ran for now I'm gonna think of
that gif with that chick coming around
the coat the bush yeah that's me like I
know it's look generations like this
generation has shown especially the end
of this generation that gaming is
changing like you look at where 23 what
26 one week 2013 started to where we are
now we have cross play the cross play
with almost like really starting to get
in their mortal
better Saturday modern warfare has it
Pub G right it's gonna be right say that
cross-play are you saying that Sony is
better than me me your coded words write
your code once again so let's get up in
the knees of the chat so deep in in the
D we gotta have somethin the knees in
the chat was doing cross play with
everybody that wanted to play boys one
team that didn't want to play ball but
all of a sudden now is a different head
dude in charge mr. Ryan the capitulate
er means the beaten Bentham and blazes
happenin he's shaken and games of being
given out what is going on why is he
likes money
yeah it's but I say it's like the
everybody was show sure Sony would never
do cross play with Microsoft because
they have the user base to get a
leverage to use your base or what's
happening obviously developers really
want cross play and sona's gonna provide
a forum then there was minecraft o Sony
will never allow Xbox Live on
PlayStation Network and that happened he
thought there might be some
give-and-take there maybe Mike maybe
Microsoft you know offers them because
if you notice minecraft snot on psvr
right I would not be surprised if for
the psvr to like announcement launch
title they suddenly have minecraft
minecraft' maybe like and as far as this
MMO be thing yeah I'm sure it has a lot
to do with the contract negotiations I'm
sure it also has to do a lot with how
expensive the licenses right right so
Sony like you said if they're presented
with the option of like not agreeing to
whatever MLB wants and how they aren't
making baseball well Sony San Diego's is
geared to making baseball games do they
have to shut them down now there's a lot
of there's a lot of speculation about
why this happened right that mo be said
we wanted to be multi-platform if you
don't agree with this we'll take the
license elsewhere maybe
true you know there's also possibility
that the license became so expensive
that Sony had no choice but to sell the
game to more people to recoup their
money right the idea though that I don't
necessarily agree with is that ei was
just sitting there in the wings just
waiting to take up a baseball license
the name and made a baseball game and
God knows how long
right and we know ea doesn't really like
to make games for sports that they don't
control the exclusive license for right
right Madden is dominant because they
bought the exclusive license and be a
live and I'm sorry smooth stop mom
because now accordingly to it because
they they can't they couldn't force out
their competitor right yeah and they're
not even putting one out this year
because why bother nobody buys NBA Live
[Music]
that's perfectly fine but we look at
like MLB like they they never really did
the exclusive thing because while MLB
the show was going on they also at 2k
made the baseball license so it wasn't
like they were really interested in
exclusive stuff they just wanted to take
more money from anybody that wanted the
license I'm not really sure EA was like
yeah we need to get back into baseball
that doesn't really make just make a lot
of sense to me but where's the Superjail
no second shout-out to JT game with the
five no no no we got one right before
the does oh okay l LMNOP oh did we get
the x-men one before above that Dallas
team we need an expert ingane now for
Series X legendary show guys shoutout to
the all-star panel shoutout Victor Alice
team by LMNOP with the father chat good
afternoon to the lords field ominous
Maximus earning that paycheck great job
on that surprise reveal yes sir the last
one JD JD gamer with the $5 super chat
somebody told Microsoft to be the
behemoth that they are right before they
signed a Sony contract I think they'll
be begging to rejoin along with others
yes okay so you don't feel ready you
don't feel ei was lurking in the ring
you just feel contractually it was up
whenever be MLB president went back to
Saudi said look you know if we're gonna
redo this thing you're gonna have to
spread this to multiply and then so yeah
because I don't I don't think if he a
really wanted a license to make a
baseball game MLB black okay here you go
you know you know like I don't really
think I don't think I'm a wants big I
mean
baseball games outside of show don't
sell well I mean the to the United
States really don't so up yeah like so
and then like even even the 2k games
they stopped making the 2k baseball game
because dole sold like trash and those
were on all the consul's the Sony ones
still outsold them so like I don't see I
don't see EAB Michael we really need to
get back into baseball it doesn't make a
lot of sense to me
it doesn't but the thing is about the
license now the last time that Sony re
up the license right they did it so as
to pushed out yeah and then have the
stipulation we're only first parties
could make it right so me know could
make an in-house baseball play xbox
could make an in-house baseball that was
the stipulation this time around no
third party okay so but that was only
because of 2k not wanting to bid on the
license that was the renegotiation that
Sony put into place once 2k pulled out
cuz two K PI grants it it got to the
point where 2k didn't want to make it
anymore because MLB was just out selling
at home platform so they pulled out
completely it turned over all of their
publishing rights to baseball to to to
Sony and Sony restructured the deal and
said that only first parties going
forward the baseball game like it's like
when when a restructured the deal Sony
had the leverage right and now in this
new restructuring Sony has no leverage
people went up as you think they got the
leverage man I'm not have this mindset
that Sony like what snores to do this I
think I'm so Sounion tells them look we
need this multi ply if Sony says no
and we'll be walks away I don't know
III think it went like okay look um you
know I think Saudi realized first off I
think they did increase the licensing I
don't think Sony wanted to pay the
higher licensing and they gave them this
this other option I don't think Saudis
willingly just gonna give up an
exclusive like yeah I think that they
did it for financial gain because they
realized that first time it is a
baseball game well you know you know
Nintendo Nintendo and Microsoft had also
been at the table yes in negotiations as
well because as soon as was finalized
they knew about it and I mean so
Nintendo and Microsoft also must have
been well aware of what was going on you
know right
feels like thank God I use fan boys can
stop asking me about a baseball good
that was yeah you figured the phone and
said Ryan good job high heat license and
then it released that one game I forgot
what it was called that it wasn't high
super chair real quick for a follower X
equals power halo infinity hell blade 2
equals games unless go on Triple A and
teaching the Microsoft ways MLB going
multiplex boxes on fire all hail Phil
Dominus
Jesus cut Nero podcast is over three
hours long this is the most information
that's happened in one week in a long
time with the flat is that all this
boring baseball talk where's my NCAA
football real man's game boring baseball
talk you should listen in the beginning
when it was nothing about us
the rain III thought I used to fight
with them and I just gave up the iron
Lords are existed mm-hm you zyk track
hello the other day you know it's one of
those things that you know a lot of
people were upset but again Saudis in
the business are making money they
cannot lose this license they cannot
have my man tryin to capitulated like he
said I think I don't think overall they
were forced to do anything I just think
it was mostly like Rand just said it
came down to dollars and cents and Sony
was like hold up before we didn't have
to pay extra money because the rice is
coming over to us from a third party now
you're asking us to flip the whole deal
and they're like we don't sell that many
goddamn baseball games and in the fact
that people look at the hundred million
and say man why can't baseball sell more
well you gotta dig nine hundred million
isn't baseball fans right you know won't
be associative that is in America hey
will you cut out the other side of that
which is the Xbox brand which
predominantly is based in America that's
the fans that want to play the game more
than anything so I think he MIB was like
hey you can flip the deal because I
think they love their baseball game
because that's the one thing I will say
their baseball game is above all there's
nothing superior game superior
experience so I think they were like we
would love we don't want to lose it can
we love the baseball game you make but
if you want to keep the right make it
other places or pay for the rights for
it offer yourself up front right and the
game will be played more of that like
game paths I'm like that mm-hmm
like because I will play baseball in
game path actually
putting a game like that in game path
before they make their own
que paso PlayStation what do you think
what do you think about a MLB the show
2021 looking best on series acts I don't
think they're gonna do that look give
them the key doesn't matter like they
were taking the Pro generation going
forward period bar none Phil is not
backing down from nobody
yo when he stepped on that stage if you
didn't see anyone want to bring the knee
with him on that if you didn't see the
declaration in everybody's face when the
world was watching he said you know what
not everybody gonna watch EXO but some
Sony dudes is gonna be here he came out
right here for this stage for these
people to let these people know right
now is the time I'm drawing a line in
the sand how and speed and we gonna be
the lead platform you won't develop us
first you gonna trickle it backwards for
them to have done what anyway I'll get
my last way to go oh listen good thing
you know more people get to play the
game it's the best baseball game bar
none is no simulation baseball even
close MLB the show is to go as far as
artists as far as baseball concern great
to see it and we forgetting about the
elephant in the room solve our baseball
we're also getting the game we know they
can do it no potato was doing MOV the
show so when a whole cutscenes the
screen it's gonna have the textures of
an n64 games which gang don't you worry
because like I said the Vita was able to
do it so we shall see not gonna get the
Vita virgins no il people this week with
the recent reveal announcement of the
Xbox series X at the Game Awards do you
think this was the right move by
Microsoft to reveal the console details
now ahead of the PS 5 the choices are a
to soon gives Sony PS 5 ample time to
counter be perfect timing excited to
baste and showed renewed confidence in
the brand or C I don't care it's still
look like the sex box to me when it goes
up shout out to the amazing all-star
special guest panel Rand outdoor much
gaming kids smooth game before it's a
acre bed nor red Wiccan the five people
find you what you have going on sir
probably definitely not on IOP after
this three-hour plug yeah yeah you did
thanks for having me on I had a blast
even though it was three hours long but
yeah I just I love the excitement I love
that everyone's kind of getting like
more and more back into the what Xbox
is doing you know it's been you know
rough couple years and um yeah man I'm
I'm I I'm so excited man you can check
me out you know obviously my youtube
channel around Oh Thor 19 search it out
there call it cider right outdoors I am
not intense I don't know I'm just saying
I people sometimes people tell me stuff
I mean I don't claim to be an insider so
what about that glorious xbox to podcast
with Windows central oh just fine
what Thursdays normally depends on one
minute me and Jess can do it on on my
youtube channel as well as we put it up
on iTunes and nice you know Spotify so
people can listen that way as well
salute to Rand outdoor one of the
balanced voices in the Xbox community
always a pleasure to do you know podcast
with them and you don't let do we always
welcome you in a room any time and thank
you for rocking out three hours
surviving MMA talk all the suffering you
would do to get salute there man because
again we were talking and this was fun
to have him on ever been on in a while
so salute the red real quick super Chad
Lord zero I LP just want to wish
everyone a happy holiday before the show
wrapped up to Rams point we are watching
gaming evolved before our eyes it's
exciting and who could get JD gamer
which he speaks the truth devs develop
games for the most powerful platform
first then xx then o to the platforms
Xbox is the best Fox access my game for
this podcast 100 no kid smooth in the
room I had to try to get in as VIP I
knew it was a packed house but I had to
get some my beds I knew what if this
move it
kiss whoa what is going on we can if I'm
people find you what you got going on oh
man find me on Twitter I've been getting
people mad all week Twitter action
smooth mixer calm slash I am kiss moving
of course YouTube / kiss move so yeah
man thanks for having me he's been great
I couldn't wait to this episode
whether I was in there or watch me down
but yeah man good good show I noticed
how you was straight to uh to cogito for
that if I can ask me it was tough it was
a tell but I it was no way Blake I
cannot I always low-key hoping he would
because I knew we were fooling I've cast
I just said you know what this is one of
the moments where you just say kid I
deem this the turning point a demoness
actually I want you to put that in there
in the title somewhere had a best Bob
man he'd been riding the front line so
he deserved this moment always a brother
to the IOP so salut kiss move in the
building coming through Lord mods gaming
with the technical break that getting
attacked on Twitter for for promoting oh
it's a war for like five six hours over
this man yesterday how damn mods give us
take breakdowns in music who is he who
made him the authority I ever
PlayStation game this tech don't matter
oh good I mean listen you know it must
be this MLB I mean honestly you know I
just you know I just learned to ignore
the them and I don't even speak with him
I don't reply to them because that that
just you know get things worse right but
you know a but he actually said that
I've got that good channel so you know
so you got some credible you cheer
that's good hey guys thanks so much for
having me great show as always very good
news coming you know into the from the
Xbox campus stuff right check me out on
youtube mods gaming there America they
think about you can't do is plug on your
own platform that'll make sense joining
the realm salute brother poppin we got a
lot of content for you badly yeah shoot
the Bison hopefully mods this 2020
meeting yeah we get you for two castles
yeah hopefully home yeah yeah yeah it's
going to be a great year so yeah thanks
Allen Rachael appreciated brother Lord
gay week for the retail King breaking it
down helping us be unconfused in the
rest I don't know if you should call
retail qicang my throw away but they
might be retail lord pull it up last
minute oh no man no problem you know
Lord's call I come man always loved
being on the show section stellar
roundtable act as it is today but this
gave me Forte on YouTube and Twitter and
man the biggest thing I always want to
communicate is I've never seen so much
positivity in one week from a group of
people because it's been a long time
coming for people that just love playing
on xbox and everything and like I always
tell people you know don't be a slave to
just one theme because when you love
everything you're never disappointed
never disappointing when you love
everything thank you for joining the
Brotherhood that's mostly it you know
just hit me up on those platforms as I
was in the industry know on top of me
wanted to look and look at everybody
else's reactions and stuff I was
actually making a video for the first
time in like almost a month because I
was that excited Microsoft finally was
funny so he was like the sex was too
much for amazing show guys I don't mind
three hours because I'm not doing
anything but playing destiny as I first
for the first time in a while I didn't
play a game during the podcast salute
you for focused as the co-host thank you
when you focus thank you does little or
take of it I definitely pulled up in the
realm
also helping us out Lord addict man you
waited for this day it has come waked to
find people find you what you got going
on sir you can find me on Twitter too
Lord Alex ILP pretty sure that's my tag
these days I don't know
changing it because while they say going
on you can find me in these Twitter
streets laying these PlayStation fanboys
you you can D me the brat killer as well
definitely first of all appreciate all
the love we got today on the chat you
know a lot of you came through a lot of
you stay consistently uh everyone that
it members that I subscribe to the
membership I appreciate it
everyone that super Chad you have no
idea how much that helps the podcast
until next week I'm sure a pretty sure
we're doing the podcast nice but I don't
know what about with that so you know
definitely appreciate everyone coming
through the MLB start out to everybody
in the panel this was insane today and
just more people to popping in and
popping in and popping in as a made man
like Forte said there's so much
positivity around this it is a long time
coming so it is fact and it's yeah man
like just what's coming up for me
nothing work I gotta go to work oh me
too
I do that I hand off patting myself on
the back for all we did to cry your
lawyer you want again you know he won't
be one with second bears once again
defending his way who is second place
with the predictions of the gay boys
explained to Lord Cognito with eight
correct answer nice ILP generally we in
the bushes yes donut zero on eight
categories Wow I think every so wait you
know why cause I didn't play half those
guys really good
you just went with desk writing
everything are you saying cuz it wasn't
fixed you lost Twitter loss of IOP BX
Xbox Live and PSN I'm trying to finish
they were waiting all week all I heard
was tweets we'd be to hear from King
this week what is good or wicked if I
have to go find you I want to thank
everybody that showed up on the panel
today I didn't expect this to be honest
with you I get a lot of questions in the
morning because I'm really dead by the
time I get in in the morning and um how
the hell you have energy to do a show
it's wrong best person that was in that
chat every last person that got up every
last person that stood here viewed your
level of participation was not minimized
at all if you gave in the chat if you
joined you were here you were present
I'm going to be here and I'm going to be
present for you as well so I salute
every last person that got up and this
is amazing it's absolutely amazing it
blows my mind every week every day even
when I tweet it just blows my mind I'm
like I said I'm gonna give a shout-out
to the panel um kids move 100% you know
you have definitely been their rock and
100% won from from from the second me
you had that conversation about the you
know like finances on some other stuff
it has been completely love I love your
energy I love everything about
everything you do game and Forte my man
the king of retail
your insight on stuff it's so amazing I
just marvel that stuff that you know and
how you can quell a room from the
fear-mongering with people going inside
stores and being ignorant knowing if you
are in your mind telling these people
what they need to do and how they need
to do it and mods your level of
technical know-how is amazing
I read your articles and you know for
ignorant like myself reading your stuff
you allow me to see through your eyes
and learn and I appreciate it I
appreciate all your hard work that you
do
Rand outdoor you are part of a trifecta
that I watch on YouTube that I consume
my stuff daily and you have been on fire
brother you have literally been on fire
and I think most of the time I'm like ah
sometimes you get so on fire that I got
to pull out my phone as I'm watching it
on my xbox I mean doesn't have a part
where I can go in there to chat and
leave our message I pull out my phone
and I go and watch the video again while
I'm leaving a message at the bottom of
the screen telling you the King approves
this this is fantastic stuff yeah I
really love your work and I do
appreciate all the hard work everybody
here it was a fantastic day
king of the statues you can catch that
every week this week we had the
hobgoblin up the companion statue in the
background is a Ghost Rider those are
the one term scale those are the budget
line you can get them a little bit
cheaper 125 this week coming up I'm
gonna do something special for you guys
I got some books in from I'm sideshow
it's the anatomy of the metahuman really
thick book pause also you know we have
the DC Comics supervillain the
encyclopedia we're gonna go through that
and I have a box over there full with
toys that you guys were asking me do I
collect toys well if you see you can see
a little bit of stuff here these are the
stuff that supposed to either go to eBay
I just can't even sell them I'm not
gonna even do it I'm putting them
upstairs because I can't bring myself to
sell something for monetary game I don't
mean the money well are they trying to
say your statues or toys
well you know sometimes when say stuff
like oh that toy like you know the jug
and I'm stuff like that that's $1600 I
don't care what you think but I do got
some actual toys that I'm gonna show one
one six nine scale toys that we don't
talk about cuz no true instinct alright
that's that got to come down and drag
this out long enough
oh you can catch me on Twitter and also
I got a combat talk coming up this week
so everybody salute man chat was
absolutely fantastic I don't even know
what to say but I definitely blown away
the fact that you even care about what
US ignoramus is gonna say if I gave that
it's gotta Bob love a salute to the
panel McGann Lord Ram for answering the
call always a pleasure to have them in
the room Lord mods of course kids move
the legendary the best part
and of course gaming forte and the
anchorman man this is tremendous
oh yeah yeah day one may guy responsible
for a lot of us talking to each other
you know but yes so salute dad to chat
with fantastic you already know um the
last word is up we blonde says please
check that out and that's all I got man
everybody enjoy your Sunday thanks for
rocking with us with technical
difficulties until next Sunday is the
last 11 a.m. of 2019 22 21 next so 1:00
p.m. we no longer bend the knee to
football get might be war it might start
one p.m. next week yeah mice coming up
your team is eliminated we don't care we
still go it is really everybody enjoy
you said you we are here